Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Barn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday, Monday
morning podcast, and I
just checking in on you.
Just checking in to see how you're doing,
man. Shit, by the way, I'm
also checking in specifically if
they can fucking still hear me.
Anybody who stuck around in
North Carolina, Virginia,
wherever else. The Carolinas,
the CACA.
Lackeys.
Okay,
I fucking going anywhere. God Damn and
I got a fucking fast boat. All right.
Oh,
that turn.
I took the fucking camper off
the back of my camp or special.
I welded it to my fucking bass boat.
I am good to go. I'm like, yeah,
to see a fucking gate or
come along my way. All right.
I'll have a feast and a new pair
of fucking shoes, water moccasin.
I'll make you into a fucking
belt. Bring it on, Mother Nature.
You fucking bitch.
That's what a lot of people,
that's what a lot of people think.
People who are not leaving despite all
of the warnings are thinking that's what
they think is going on.
Right?
Okay.
I'll put on a pair of fucking snow shoes
and I'll walk right across the fucking
class. Oh, they're spin. And I don't
give a shit. I drink moonshine.
Spinning is my natural
state mother fucker.
Well,
nature coming over here like some sort
of fucking ex wife wanting more fucking
money. Um, a lot of people think that
that's what's going on. But uh, you know,
people don't understand that what the
bankers did in the two thousands is still
affecting people.
And there's a lot of people who are
still upside down in a house that's never
going to be worth more than what they,
what they owe.
The American dream is over for these
people. And when you're in that situation,
you know,
uh,
that leads to driving a piece of shit
car at least to a whole bunch of shit.
You don't have health
insurance and all of that.
So now he's supposed to get
into your fucking, you know,
questionable car and just drive a
state away with no fucking money.
You know, you got kids,
you got all of this shit.
What are you going to donate nine on the
other side? People go, Whoa, well you,
you know, you get, you
at least should be alive.
Okay?
You know what I would do now
that I'm driving, driving safe,
I would just drive to a waffle house
and I would sit in the parking lot.
You know what would happen?
The security guard at the waffle house,
there's no security.
There's no security.
They just have a fee of a bat phone
to the cops at the waffle house,
the waffle house. They have got to have
the most fucking altercations. Any just,
I mean,
it's just such a wonderful place.
You go in there to get this delicious,
unhealthy fucking food that just,
it's comfort food, you know?
And what happens every,
I swear to God, I don't care
who the fuck you are. Black,
white, male, female, Asian,
fucking and Ron Deck. You
go in there, you're, you're,
you're going to get into a fight.
You're going to see a fight.
You're going to have to pick up your
fucking waffles and move it out of the way
is somebody slams down on your table.
Like you're in some sort of
fucking saloon in the 18 hundreds.
And you're telling me these people in
North Carolina lackey are supposed to
drive to that fucking
parking lot. Well, Bill,
don't you think that's better than trying
to wait it out in a hurricane? I Dunno,
Dude. I've never had to do that. You know,
fortunately I'm not in that
financial fucking position, but um,
you know, I just don't understand how
these fucking back has got away with that.
Joe. I understand how they did
it and they're doing it again.
But these luxury high rise apartment
buildings that they're fucking building
everywhere.
What kind of a fucking jerk off rents?
A luxury high rise apartment building.
Okay.
Don't do that by a piece of Shit House.
At least at the end of living there,
you can sell it and get
some of your money back.
You may or may not make a profit,
but I'm just saying, you know,
all you Instagrammers, you
know, it's really interesting
that I didn't realize, uh,
do you know old millennials are, everybody
is looking and let myself included.
You. Look at college kids,
he's fucking millennials. They,
they can't do anything for themselves.
They're not millennials. All right.
Millennials, the first millennials,
you know what year they were born? 1980
okay. To 19, I think. 95.
So millennials right now,
or 22 to 38 and I imagine this some other
uninformed shitheads like me out there
who are 38 years old and
talking about people who are 18,
calling them fucking millennials
when they are not millennials,
but the person is saying it is actually
a fucking millennial. All right, people.
Now you got to know what
generation you're talking about.
Like, you know what's funny,
I'm actually generation x.
So I was after the baby boomers
and that ended in like, I dunno,
63 or 64 or something like that.
And then generation x went up to 1979.
And what's funny is I did not, I did, I,
I don't identify as Gen x.
No generation next to me
was the Seattle music scene.
That's when I started fucking hearing it.
Um,
I don't think, but I didn't think
the baby boomers were like, hey man,
we got to get out of Vietnam,
man.
Fucking baby killer man.
Right?
I feel like this should be a generation
between baby boomers and generation x.
You know, that generation
that like Ronnie James Dio,
you know, but you know, didn't listen
to the Mamas and the Papas. Oh,
the leads are proudly supra
and this guy is great.
Like that shit.
Um,
I like to watch your Mama Cat's dance.
She had a fucking cool little
two step she used to do. Um,
anyways, I don't know what the fuck I'm
talking about right now. I'm just saying,
you know, uh, good luck
to all of those people.
I'm coming in next week if it's not under
fucking water. I really hope it isn't.
And uh,
you know,
I dunno, this is crazy.
This is just fucking crazy.
I know we always had hurricanes and stuff,
but like I just hope they're not going
to keep getting worse and the sheer
amount of them, um, you know,
there's nothing worse than watching
people lose everything. Right. Um,
if only there was a way to fix this.
Mother Nature is trying right now,
trying with the only the quickest swiftest
fucking solution that's literally,
you know, metaphorically what
she's doing right now going,
I see what the problem is. I need to
drown some of these motherfuckers.
I need to drown a certain amount of
them. Right. But she's going to have,
the scary thing is she's going to have
to do way better than what she's doing
right now because we
always worn everybody out,
right.
The storms coming in and everybody
gets the fuck out of dodge.
So Mother Nature has gotta be walking
around just shaking her head after every
one of these things going.
I'm telling you I don't,
it doesn't make any fucking sense.
She's like, Mr Pink, you know,
telling me we've got to fucking rat.
Okay. When those alarms going off,
you got 15 minutes. I'm telling you, go
to the cops. They were just there, man.
They were just there already.
All loaded for bear.
Now I know. Am I right? I'm
fucking positive. You're like,
I got to watch that movie again.
Um, yeah, Mother Nature got be.
We got to fucking rat in the
house. Okay. So who's, uh,
who's Tim Roth? Terentino's.
Mr. Brown. Like Mr Shit.
Mr Pink, Mister Blonde. Mr. White.
Mr Orange.
Yeah.
She has to find out who are Mr oranges
and her mister orange is the fucking
weather channel. You know,
she's got to come in there.
So you like to tell jokes are giggling
like a bunch of girls in a school yard.
Well,
I got a job for you.
MMM.
Anyways,
uh,
I have been working out, I've been eating
right and I got to tell you guys, uh,
I'm in like the fucking best shape
I've been in in years and uh,
it is fucking unbelievable. I know
people always told me Diet, it's,
it's 90% died now he five to
85% to 70% die. Dude, it's,
it's all diet.
It's all diet.
Because like if you can go kick the shit
out of yourself and a God damned gym,
jump on a fucking elliptical, you jump
on elliptical and you can for an hour
burns 600 calories according
to that fucking computer,
which how the fuck it knows how
much burning versus somebody else.
You know what happened? So
it's an estimate. So you,
you've sweat all over the fucking thing.
You don't wipe it off because you're a
selfish cunt. You go walking out of there,
right.
And then later on that night,
all you got to have like three and a half
for Oreo cookies and you just negated
that workout.
Done.
Okay.
All of that fucking work
out the window and you can,
you can fucking got a minute and a half.
Yeah.
You know what it's like,
it's like every, when we,
whenever we put out these seasons,
F is for family.
It takes us like fucking 14 months to
finish them. And then people just not,
not saying, you know, that's
how kids watch it. Not Saying,
I don't want you to go.
I'm just saying. Then they
just come back like, hey man,
like what's the next season coming out?
Same thing,
same thing. Um, I uh, went out and I,
I'm actually like a,
I am off sugar and salt to the point
I asked my wife to go out and get some
almond butter and she got it.
And I already knew there was something
going on with that where it says you
didn't have to stir this shit.
And I'm like,
this doesn't sound like the nat just
doesn't feel like the natural shit.
So I put it in this smoothie,
two tablespoons of this
shit, and I meet, I say,
let's just fucking sugar in this.
And after like for like a five weeks,
I've been eating like this. Like it
literally almost made my, my fucking,
I made like a, like a bit into
a lemon, like Jesus Christ.
And I never noticed that beforehand.
So if you're old like me
and you want to regain
some of your old glory,
you want to drive down the street
with the areas to look back.
You want to put the dog down,
you want to tell these bitches what
time it is. Um, it's all about diet.
Your abs are there, man. If you didn't
have a, I don't have abs. Yes you do.
If you didn't have abs, you could
not sit up in bed. You know,
you couldn't even roll out of bed.
You need your obliques could not roll
out of bed to go downstairs and eat a
chocolate chip muffin or whatever other
stupid thing that you're gonna do that's
gonna make you break a blood vessel.
When you fucking sit down, you know,
let's sit down that you do. When you
get really out of shape where you, you,
you lose,
you use your leg muscles and at some
point it just becomes a free fall into the
couch.
You'd give yourself whiplash and your
fucking head hits the table that your wife
just had to have that was just a
little bit higher than the couch.
You put them up, fuck right? And
then immediately what happened? What?
This fucking table here I
liked, I thought, look nice.
And now you're in a fight,
right?
And now you're going to work telling your
friends that you're not getting along
with your wife and what a fucking bitch
she is in all of this type of shit.
And when it really comes down to is
you're just, you're not eating right,
you're not eating right.
So you literally have to do a
fall into your fucking couch.
You get a fucking mild
concussion on the [inaudible]
giant end table that she
just had just had to have it.
And he's like,
for what?
I'm loving the yet and
southern accent lately,
I kind of disguises that. It's actually
my own ignorance saying it. Oh No,
I was just doing a character.
Well, they got a woman doing
play by play in the NFL.
Oh my God. You got a big kid
then went over these women,
they don't even Lachsport.
Oh, they do. Then what a fuck.
And there are only eight people at a
w NBA game. You explain that to me?
No women on the car. Well,
anti feminists aren't.
Why aren't these feminists out
there to fucking at the God damn,
uh, whatever they're
called Oklahoma Twat game.
Well,
why don't you watch an episode of the
real housewives maybe figure out that's
why they don't show up.
Shit.
Okay.
Maybe they're three minutes. They'd be
fucking lunging over a goddamn table.
They ain't give me no camera, man.
There are not enough camera man. Right.
Break it up.
Um,
I went down a Randy Newman, a rabbit
hole the other night. Jesus Christ.
That guy's talented. Huh? And when that's,
I'm old enough to remember when that
song, yeah. Show up. People got no reason.
Show up. People got no reason. Job.
People got no reason to live.
And that came out and all these
shore people got mad and he was,
he was making fun of racism. The
ridiculousness of racism, right?
It got a little cars go beep, beep
beep. They got little voices going,
pee, pee, pee grubby little
hands, dirty little mind.
And people once again took it at face
value. But you know, having said that,
that song came out and then there was a
bunch of people that didn't get what it
was about and they were singing
it to short people. So I dunno,
it was so brilliant on so many
different levels. And I love his voice.
I love the piano he plays
and he's done all these,
all these great songs from
movies and stuff like that.
And I actually looked up to see
if he was a touring anywhere.
Um, there's some really great footage of
them to actually with that short people
think where he's in the studio, like
an incredible credible sense of humor,
you know, as most, you know,
geniuses that I've seen always self
deprecating and that type of stuff.
Um, it's really funny
how that is, you know,
people who stick just walk around like,
like they're fucking astronauts.
Just supreme confidence, you
know, always thinking they killed,
let's just no fucking
clue where it's just like,
it's just one of those fucking
things, you know? I Dunno,
that's always a red flag to me
when someone's walking around.
Maybe that's my own fucking thing.
Maybe that's the Boston thing,
like easy the kid, don't forget where
you came from. Fucking relax. Easy.
They're Travolta.
Um,
anyways. Uh, what else?
What else is there to talk about?
I've just been, yeah, I was, you know,
and it was fucking amazing.
I was watching this episode last night,
Sunset Strip and they
showed the Coanda pass,
which is where the one oh one goes
from a Hollywood into the valley.
And,
um,
there's this old bridge and they were
showing like footage of it from the 1950s
and I'd seen this before at
a car dealership that had
all these old pictures of
Hollywood.
And you see on the one on one between the
one on one north and one on one on one
south at the Coanda passes in between
the are railroad tracks that no longer
exist. And it's always like, you
know, they used it. They, the city,
believe it or not, from what you
know, the tree huggers saved me on,
had one of the greatest, uh,
public transportations of any city.
And the conspiracy theory is that the
oil company companies and a Goodyear tire
created a corporation and they
bought up all the street cars,
all the trains and all the
trolleys and all that type of shit.
A bought it up and just
ripped up all the tracks,
paved over everything and forcing
people to all have to drive.
So then they like,
they,
they would make so much fucking money
that they could buy a business as big as
that with trains who can afford
to throw out of one fucking train,
forget about a whole city full of them.
Streetcars and trolleys and all that
ripped up all the fucking tracks. I mean,
I don't know what happened,
but there's something
happened cause it may,
it makes no sense.
You know,
street were the best.
They know.
They still have them in like San Francisco
and want to talk about the stupid one.
We'd go up the fucking hill like you were.
I mean those old school,
the ones that I grew up seeing,
mmm,
I dunno, but they're actually
there. They're building a,
they are building public
transportation out here again.
So, uh, we shall see.
It's weird though because everything then
got built up like everybody had a car.
So,
uh,
like most buildings just to go from the
sidewalk to the building is I give it go
to Vegas and you're like,
oh,
I'm going to walk across the street
to this other casino in like fucking,
you know, 15 minutes later you're on your
hands and knees going like water, water.
Like it's like an illusion.
It looks like it's right there.
It's right across the street.
It is so fucking far away. Um,
I know the, uh, at Csus,
what's hilarious is you can
go from the Mirage to the, uh,
to Caesars and they just have this
moving air conditioned sidewalk,
you know, and there's just all these
fat, sweaty people on it. You know,
the thing should actually be
moving in the opposite direction,
should be a giant treadmill for these
people and you should have to walk on it
for 10 minutes, then it
shuts off and rolls the other
way. You should. You should,
you should have to earn it, you
know? Um, they've just be too much,
too much liability. Somebody has a
heart attack, somebody slips and falls.
So they don't,
they just conveyor belt.
You don't like cattle off
to slaughter Jesus bill.
Why can't you speak people who are
just fat and happy, you know, going in,
you know, wearing their favorite
loud shirt to go play some craps.
You know what you know, I think you
guys might have a point on this one.
Um, so anyways, the first
week of NFL has gone by.
Now you know what everybody's doing.
Everybody looks at week one and then they
just say that's who these people are.
The New York jets. Are they
the favorites? Any AFC aged?
Yeah,
they won one game. Um, I'll tell
you the Patriot looked good,
but all of a sudden a,
it came back and made it really good
clothes. If I was a paid for and
I would be a good chat about that.
I don't know about you guys. Don't you
feel like there's about three weeks in?
Okay.
You know, you can kind of start to tell
like, okay, this, this team is this,
this team is that. And then
there's, you know, injuries.
I don't know what the
fuck's going to happen,
but I really don't think that the Tampa
Bay Buccaneers are going to put up 48
points a week while letting up 40
or the saints going to let up 48.
I don't fucking know.
Right.
Cincinnati are going to go down by 20
every fucking week and then come roaring
back and fucking wait. I
don't know. Maybe they will.
Maybe this is what's going to happen.
MMM.
Tell you right now Cincinnati,
I mean if this is what we're
going to be most exciting season.
MMM.
Anyways, so I am going to, uh,
I'm going to be in town this
whole weekend because I have,
I have a bunch of big gigs coming up.
So, uh, I am touring like I used to tour,
so I have like one weekend off until
like towards the end of October.
And um, but this weekend obviously
got moved to next weekend,
which was my only weekend off.
So it Kinda worked out. And um,
yeah.
So my wife was going, hey, I got
some stuff to do Saturday afternoon.
Do you mind?
You know,
hanging out with our daughter and
blah, blah, blah. It's like, what,
why are you got to use?
Of course I don't.
Of course we have to hang with my
daughter and watch Lsu versus Auburn.
Are you kidding me?
This is a dream.
So fucking drink. Well, I ain't
going to be a dream that God,
a God damn broad announcing
the fucking game.
Um, it would still be a dream. I
don't give a shit. Welcome ladies.
Welcome to the world of
broadcasting. Uh, anyways, uh,
yeah, I can't wait to my, we took
our daughter over to get some shots,
you know what I mean? Like, uh,
I decided to stop listening to Hollywood
celebrities and actually listen to
people in the medical field.
So my daughter is getting all the shots.
We stretched them out or whatever.
So she went there to get like her shot.
So she's been there numerous times.
And um,
so now like she knows when we go in there
that this is the place where she feels
that needle and stuff. So she's like
all nurse. She's like, you know,
when I used to bring my dog to
the vet, you know, same thing.
So I'm trying to make a laugh and stuff.
So we ended up going in there and
the woman neuros, she's great.
She's just real quick gets it done.
And um,
my daughter said her first three
words sentence after she got the shot,
like she was already
crying when we laid back,
anticipating and then she got the shot
and then she, uh, she let out this yell,
uh, just broke my heart and
then she looked at the nurse
and she just goes right
odd John,
bye bye.
Like it was so funny.
Fucking cute. And it also like
broke my heart all at the same time.
I picked her up and she, you know,
a little hand grabbing a handful of
my shirt,
like Terry O'Reilly back in the day,
but she's trying to hug me and she just
kept looking at the nursery nurse goes,
it's all okay. That's it. Yeah. All
done. And She just kept [inaudible].
Oh,
bye bye bye bye.
Was just like, it was like a
kid going, I don't, you know,
who the fuck away from me,
man, bye bye. Like I can't,
I can't even, I can't even recreate, um,
okay.
That moment. And um, it's so,
I was so glad that I was there as a
dad cause I gotta be honest with you.
Like I would stay out in the waiting
room because I, I could not handle,
I was hearing those babies crying
then I was just like, you know,
I don't know that I could, I can
handle, even if it's a good thing,
watching somebody on any level,
hurting my kid and I know that
they're doing it for the right thing,
but it was just like, uh,
so I went in there. MMM.
And I, I got through it and uh, I'm
glad I did. I was glad that I did.
And uh, it was, oh my God,
it was so fucking cute.
It was so cute. Oh, I'd done well. I buy
bye.
I just kept saying that like, like, like
I'm done with you. Get away from me.
I don't want any more of this shit.
I just can't,
I can't like the emotion in her voice.
I just can't put into fucking words
for whatever reason. Um, anyways,
let's do some advertising here.
Oh,
the week my bookie, everybody, I called
them in every week or I call in a,
do they have a plot?
I didn't know what the fuck does is call.
I'm so God damn busy. I know. I call it
a couple people and I do my pics here.
All right. My bookie, you know,
ever since I, yeah. This podcast,
people have been asking me yeah. For
advice. Ask me what team to bet on.
The truth is, I dunno, I dunno
who's gonna win. I don't know. Shit.
I can't even name half the
quarterbacks in the league.
I keep forgetting the name of the guy in
the Texans who's fucking incredible, uh,
Watson, Dante, Derek,
deandre, something, one of those
cool black ID names, Watson.
Uh, but if you think, you know,
you got to check out my bookie,
remember who you remember.
Who you're betting on is just as,
as important as who you, who
you're betting with. Guy.
This copy is written so well and I fuck
it up. Let me try it. Try this again.
The truth is, I don't know who's going
to win, but if you think you know,
you got to check out my bookie,
remember who you bet non is just as
important as who you betting with.
That's why people always tell
you to bet with my bookie.
Trust them. They're your
best bet this season. They've
been in business for years.
They got great reviews online and their
mobile site is easy to use. My bookie,
you, when they pay, this
isn't in the copy you lose,
you pay. Um, I mean, yeah, obviously
if you win, they pay. Well.
What does that supposed to be
like? A great thing. Holy Shit.
She actually pay me if I win.
Wow. Finally an honest bookie.
Anyways,
they have in game live betting the most
rewarding player parks in the business.
And for you,
fantasy football play in guys out there,
you can even bet the under the,
over under,
on how many fantasy points a player
will score each game. Mike Muslin tests.
My favorite shit, the bed, uh,
my book he is other than, uh,
other than taking points. I love taking
points. I love taking the points.
I love the underdog. You know, uh,
my bookie is slammed and with new betters
and wants to give everyone the best
service possible. If you're willing
to deposit after 7:00 PM eastern time,
they will give you an additional,
an additional $25 free
play on deposits over $100.
So many people using this site,
they're actually trying to delay you
delinquence from calling in man. So, uh,
get an exit 25 bucks if you do
it after 7:00 PM eastern time.
Join now at my book and my bookie will
match your deposit dollar for dollar use
Promo Code Burr B u r.
R to activate the offer.
That's visit my visit my bookie
online today. That's my bookie,
m y B o, O, k, I. E.
And don't forget to use the Promo Code
[inaudible] when creating your account to
claim up to $1,000 in free play.
And now if you're willing
to hold after pm 7:00 PM,
you get an extra $25 using the
Promo Code [inaudible], B u r r.
And listen after the podcast before
the throwback clips to my call into the
sports gambling podcast. That's what
it is, was Sean Green and Ryan Kramer.
Okay.
It says, mention who you talked
about. Who did I talk about? Uh,
we talked about the jets.
We talked about Aaron Rodgers.
Um, and what, what games did
we pick this week? You don't,
I don't remember. We talked that we
talked to all kinds of football. Um,
I know I don't remember. I have no idea.
I have no idea. We talked about the bills.
You talked about the dolphins,
lot of AFC stuff.
And then we talked about the eagles.
We talked, we talked football people.
All right. Do you like football? Listen to
the Goddamn podcast. All right. He looks,
everybody who likes,
there's nobody on the planet like you.
So why would you buy a fucking generic
mattress built for everyone else?
Next, please mention all the
talking points below while
I was Gunna, you wrote it.
I'm going to, I'm going
to read. He looks sleep.
Malik's matches your body to the perfect
mattress so you get the best sleep of
your life.
They develop nine different mattresses
tailored to the specific body types and
sleep preferences.
Just go to helix,
how sleep.com/bird to take
their two minutes sleep quiz,
and then they'll match you to a mattress
that perfectly fits you contouring to
your body to provide unprecedented
comfort and better sleep.
You know when you lay on your side
and your beer belly just digs into the
mattress,
they'll pep a little concave spot there
just for you when your belly right, uh,
you got a lot of chest hair
and you sleep on your stomach.
They even have a mattress for that.
36% of Helix Helix sleep customers
report better sleep after watching,
switching to their customized
mattress from helix sleep.
Right now they're offering
up to $145 on all mattresses,
whether you're a side sleeper, a hot
sleeper, like a plush or referred bed,
they've got the mattress that will
fit just right. I sleep on my back.
I lay the, like I'm in a coffin
occasionally on the right shoulder,
maybe on the left.
Never on the stomach though.
My back has been too fucked up to lay
on my stomach for years. For decades.
I lay on my stomach and then all
of a sudden I'm just like, ah,
turnover roll out of the bed,
got to start stretching.
Um, anyways, get up to $125, you know,
every time I get on the floor too,
I think there's going to be something
under the bed. I never got over that.
You know, it's weird. I'm not really
a religious guy, but I definitely,
some of the go shit even though
I don't believe in that either.
You know what I do and I get on the floor
and I start thinking there's something
looking at me under the bed.
You know, I get over it.
I just give whatever's under the, under
the uh, bed, the finger, you know,
cause I figure if there's something
underneath there and I give it the finger,
it's going to kill me. That's
going to be over. Right.
And then if it doesn't do anything like
does he have enough that underneath
there or it's a fucking, it's a
fucking bitch. It's a pussy, right?
It's one of the bitch coaches. Um,
uh, whether you're a side sleeper,
a hot sleeper,
like a plush or affirm bed,
they've got the mattress to fit you just
right. Get up to $125 off helix. Helix,
sleep.com/bird.
That's h e l I x sleep.com/burr
for $125 off your mattress order.
Oh look who's here.
[inaudible] get the fuck.
Got a dodge.
Doodoo.
Doodoo Mandy's undies.
You're going to drown in your lodge when
they tell you to leave your state drive
to a waffle house.
It'll be great.
And your balls will be nice and soft and
there'll be fucking dry cause you're,
we'll be out of the flood zone.
Then you go back to your moldy house.
Yeah.
Hey, look for Sean Penn. He'll be
driving around in his boat. All right,
me undies. Uh, you've heard
me obsess over me undies.
You've heard me talk about how much they
are three times softer than cotton and
come with fun new prints each month.
But I got a big scoop that I'm
so excited to share with y'all.
Mian he's just gave their
membership a massive upgrade.
Members will also pay
less for everything on me.
Andy's website with
special member pricing.
That means if you want a
second pair of me undies,
a Bralette or lounge pants, you'll
pay less than anyone else. Oh,
what the fuck? Or lounge pants. I want
some. The membership. I don't like.
Listen, don't send me any me
undies. Okay, I got enough shit.
I'm trying to fucking get rid of
stuff. Lounge pants, all that's,
how do you lay off lounge
pants, honey, could you, well,
what do you we ask you made it
those stuff for sweetheart kid.
You see I'm in my lounge pants.
What did we say?
What I have on my lounge pants
and meet some fucking loud gin.
Well,
maybe I do have to yell because obviously
you didn't hear it the fucking first
time. Oh, go to your
mothers. Go to your mother.
She wanted to go there anywhere. Yeah.
How come my mother never comes over? Huh?
All of a sudden we're too fucking
busy. One of my relatives, right?
Lounge pants by me undies. Um,
you'll pay less than anyone else.
The membership comes with no strings
attached. You can switch styles,
skip the month or cancel anytime
that they come with a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee.
If you don't love him,
just send it back for a full refund.
Me undies has a great offering or
for a great offer. For my listeners,
my listeners,
for any first time purchasers,
when you purchase any me on these,
you get 50% off the free shipping.
This is a no get 50% off a pair of the
most comfortable undies you will ever put
on.
Yeah,
to get your fifth to get your 15% off
your first pair of free shipping and 100%
satisfaction guarantee,
go to [inaudible] dot com
slash [inaudible] that's
[inaudible] dot com slash
[inaudible] Yonnie's dot com slash
burp all right, that is the podcast.
All right, the Thursday
afternoon podcast. Now.
Now you get the little transition
music and then you get an x.
You get two extra fucking things here.
This is incredible.
You're going to get to listen to me
talking to what the hell did it go?
Yeah.
Uh, the sports gambling podcasts
was Sean Green and Ryan,
um, you get to listen to my pitch. She
gets to listen to my picks of the week.
I actually think my lock of the week was
that someone was going to say something
disparaging about the,
um,
okay.
The, uh, the female announcer
and I had thought as I can tell,
nothing really happened. You know, I was
just fun and right. The aunt of mine,
I said, good luck to everybody. What?
They should have a transgendered
person in that fucking do it, dude.
As long as it's still playing football,
I don't give a fuck. All right.
And as long as you know what you're
talking about, I don't know why.
I don't care what's between your legs,
what you used to have there,
what you attached, what's your carved
out? I don't, I don't give a fuck.
Just please.
For the love of God.
Know what you're talking about
and enhance the experience.
Don't take away from it,
right? In other words,
do the exact opposite of what I do
on my fucking podcast. All right,
have a great weekend. You cunts.
Uh, let's go Lsu. Actually,
Randy Newman has a song called
necks where he actually a,
he's actually making fun
of northern liberals.
Uh,
when it comes to racism, how
everybody acts. Like, you know,
all the racism is down south.
It's a song you could never write today
because of the lyrics. But you know,
if you actually knew what he was
talking about, but there's this,
there's a line in there.
Got College kids at Lsu,
uh, go in dumb. Come out dumb too.
So I figured people of Alabama would
like to listen to that one, right?
Maybe Mississippi, it's always the state
next door. Arkansas. I've noticed like,
states always think the state next to him
was fucking stupid and they're better,
you know, which is why rough and
rowdy is so fucking tremendous.
They're the only people I've
ever seen that really exploit
that state to state rivalry at the level
that people really want to take it to.
All right,
we play football because it's illegal
to just go and beat the shit out of each
other. But with rough and rowdy, like
when they had it down in the Carolinas,
I had no idea how much people in South
Carolina and North Carolina didn't care
for one another. You know, and
literally thought because that,
because of that invisible line,
if you were on the other side of it
that meant that you was some sort,
yet you will less than them.
It's fucking tremendous.
So the next rough and rowdy event,
unfortunately I'm not going to be there,
but you can bet good and God damn well,
I'm going to order it and I'm going to
tape it and I'm going to get sit down
with my Miller highlights and
I'm going to watch it. Um,
the next one I believe is in Kentucky and,
uh,
it's on October 5th,
but I have a Gig in Boston that night,
so I won't be able to do it to please,
please on tune in j Portnoy, big cat,
almost hilarious people over there.
All right. That is it.
Um, enjoy your weekend.
You can't talk to you or
eh,
Eh,
that's the way you're doing
TV
work.
Maybe get a dystonia finger bill
burr on the sports gaming bag.
Yes. Is brought to you by my
book e. Dot. Agee, my book,
he is the leader in online sports books.
Use the Promo Code Bill
Bets for 800% deposit bonus.
Play when and get paid at
my book. Dot. Agee. Okay.
Join us on the line
bill burr. Bill, I know,
I know you said you had some
travel and to do this past Sunday,
were you able to enjoy NFL week one?
Yeah, I watched the,
uh, the Patriots game,
although Mike Direct TV was
kind of cutting in and out
for whatever reason. Um,
so I watched a little bit of that.
I saw a little bit of the
jets and I watched John John
Gruden's return and I was
loving the first half was
great seeing I'm there.
I thought it was funny when we say,
and he couldn't,
he wasn't gonna be able to write to these
younger kids and they got rid of all
the young kids.
He has like the oldest team in the NFL.
I that's either going to be a, I think I
actually, I think, I think it's going to,
it's kind of a genius move on his part.
Yeah. It seemed to be a bold play to kind
of do what Gordon did and obviously the
second half didn't work out. I
mean last week we hit on it. Uh,
I think your lot cash that the,
every sports announcer will be coming
out with the sky is falling down and that
certainly seems to be the case for the
Raiders. And then on the positive side,
the jets,
well why the rate? I mean the Raiders
play like the first half state.
They weren't,
they were really good rams team.
I mean like the Raiders had
been like, like, you know,
a slapstick forever. I think
week, one night that was,
I would be happy with that
if I was a Raiders fan.
I've even known what that second half,
they didn't look coolest.
I mean it's only week one. Yeah, I know.
And the jets and now like you know,
they're already going into,
you know,
whatever that USC guy
did. Yeah. They like,
you know what he did in week one that
Tom Brady did this first week and it's
just like,
you know,
I'm not saying that that guy isn't
going to be greater I think, but like,
like I don't think you really even know
what's going on until after three weeks
as far as just like, all
right. I mean look at that,
that Tampa saints game 48 40 I mean,
is that what they're going to be
doing each week? I don't know,
given up 40 or the other way around it.
This,
that just seems like sometimes it's
just weird games and I don't think
Stafford's going to throw five
interceptions. It just, you know,
it's sometimes you just have
a bad game and, uh, I dunno,
that was, that was that jets
game. It was, um, you know,
I mean obviously if they do that every
week they're going to be world beaters,
but I got a feeling that
they're not going to be.
Yeah, I agree. And just as a, as a
someone who grew up as the jet says,
like the little brother
team just listening them,
Chan, j e t s jet, Cha Cha,
it's like calm down one win.
And that the worst heartache of
the week so far is the, you know,
Brett farbs first pass in the NFL was an
interception too. It's like calm down,
calm down there. The
judge, they're the jets.
There's too many channels.
They have to over hype everything.
But what the jets did was obviously
really impressive. Uh, and I, you know,
I'm an AFC sky, so Miami one to
and then buffalo good Lord Hills.
So yeah. Plus hello. Good Lord.
They ever going to turn it around, but
it's only one week. Who knows? But I mean,
well,
you know,
it's funny that they've set out the
patriots for the first time since 2016 or
not favorites next week. And,
um, I was sick of like, what,
2016 isn't that long ago,
you know? Yeah. So, I mean, I guess
it is as far as like, you know,
being a favorite, all of
those, all of those games,
but uh, you know, they made it seem
like it was going to be a decade ago.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, New
England, they came out,
they took care of business against the
Texans. It wasn't, it was a, it was Kinda,
it was, it was a weird
game. It didn't, it,
you never thought the
Patriots were going to lose,
but the spread seems like it
might come into a play at Gronk,
obviously looking great,
hold demos,
let him back in the game and then I'm
just sitting there with like six minutes
ago. Like, are they going to tie this up?
Like, how do we get into this situation?
All kind of like,
you know,
I was very impressed with our defense,
um,
you know, containment of
their quarterback. Like,
never can remember his fricking name
that God's not. Yeah. Yeah. Watson. Um,
but I, I our special teams, um,
kind of let up a lot of yards.
It seems like every time they ran it
back that got at least to the 30. Um,
I dunno, we shall see. But our defense
looked pretty solid. Well ain't no,
it's only one week
they finally got rid of Patricia.
We took that garbage defense to Detroit.
Oh Man. Yeah. I mean if you're,
if you're a lions fan and you watch
the super bowl and then week one Monday
night against the New York jets,
you can not be happy.
It's like you brought in
a defensive coordinator.
The defense sucked and you kept the
offensive coordinator cause you like the
chemistry and they looked like
horrible dog shit. So I dunno.
A lot of good regression angles
in the NFL for me. Exactly.
I mean that's when you're talking
about pet in the NFL, that's what you,
that's kind of what you have to do.
You have to look to opportunities
to fade some crazy outcome.
Like you said, Bill with the the box
putting up 48 points on the road.
I have a feeling Ryan Fitzpatrick
isn't going to do that week to just,
just gut instinct. There's a reason
he's not doing that every week. It's,
it's a flute.
Crazy shit happens.
Yeah. Yeah. That's the same
thing. Yeah, it was. Yeah,
it was definitely a weird,
it's a lot of weird games. Um,
but we'll also tie in from the
last time I saw tie as Lord.
What's funny is I,
one of the things I bet on this season
is there will be no tie this see I want
on it last year, the first
week of the season, Bam.
And of course it's the fucking browns.
It paid like one and a half to one. It
just seems like there's, like you said,
there's never a tie even now with only
the 10 minute over time it seems like
it's, and it's the NFL, they're not
going to end in a tie. Come on. Yeah.
They should switch it to the college
football rules for overtime because that's
such a more exciting
way to finish the game.
And then you never end up with
a tie. Hey, one and a half one.
Does that mean you had to be, you'd
have to bet two 50 to make a hundred no,
I bet a hundred and I would win one 50
plus my original bet back. So it felt,
it felt like the right,
I mean obviously it's a losing bet.
So hindsight is is what it
is. But yeah, ties are just,
both teams really tried to lose
the game and that's what we were,
we were actually out in Las Vegas
hanging out in the sports book when they
missed that field goal to end
the game and a tie and it was,
the sports looks great for dramatic
wins and losses, but dramatic ties.
It's just no one's happy. Even if you
had Cleveland plus three and a half,
you still wanted to see them hit that
field goal just to just to end the
suffering.
It was like we were at a strip club
and a dude walked down on stage like
everyone was just like, ah, fuck. Trying
to make sense of this. All right, well
this is her.
This is their best
start and over 14 years.
Best starts since 2004 which, oh
man, they were loving that step.
All right,
well let's get into some of these spreads.
Of course the spreads are brought
to you by my book, He, Daddy g,
the one of the safest online sports books.
Use the Promo Code Bill bets for
a hundred percent deposit bonus.
They got it all over their end game wage
during the prop builder play when and
get paid my bookie. Dot. Agee
promocode bill pets. All right.
First game to talk about
New England patriots.
They head into Jacksonville where
the Jaguars right now are a,
the pats actually our
favorite in this game.
They're a three point favorite
right now. Jack. Yeah,
jags are the home dog here. We're looking
at a rematch of the AFC championship,
although it was played in New
England and not Jacksonville Bill,
are you worried about the the
jags defense here on the road?
Yeah, Tom Coughlin is is
and you know obviously he,
she's beaten us twice in Superbowls
and every gun and the cup quickly.
He's turned that team around
everywhere and the guy goes, you know,
fright from back in the days
when he's at Boston College.
I'm a big fan of Tom Costs and
he's getting three points at home.
Jaguars defenses as good as I said,
I would take, I would take the Jag,
I wouldn't be afraid I would take the
Jaguars, uh, getting tiny at home.
Um, you know, [inaudible] I don't know,
I just think there were really
tough team and uh, we'll, we'll see.
We'll see. I mean, obviously
I'm rooting for the Patriots,
but we'll talk getting money here.
Yeah, exactly. You can't mess
around to keep the lights on here.
I would take the jaguars getting three.
Yeah, it does feel like that's the smart
play. I mean, you touched on it last week,
shown on the patriots generally aren't
playing their best ball in September.
And guess what,
this is the biggest game on the schedule
for the jags after blowing that game in
New England. So, I mean, look, the paths,
let a Houston team that
played pretty poorly, uh,
get back in the game and Watson was
not himself. So I'm gonna I'll say,
unless Bortles completely Bortles it.
Uh,
I think the Jags jags are
gonna win this game. Yeah.
It and you talk about Tom Kauflin style,
the way to beat New England is the,
to try and get pressure on Tom Brady with
just using your defensive line and not
blitz and a bunch of guys and Yup.
The jags have that strong defensive
line that might be able to well my that
dominate the game but certainly
pressure Brady enough and uh,
I I think what the, the paths have
going for them is Leonard for net.
Looks like he's going
to be after the jags.
Jack's don't have a ton of
offensive weapons. Honestly,
I think the play in this game
maybe, uh, maybe to go under,
it feels like it's going to
be a little slug match here,
but I'll take the jags catching
three and a rematch and um, yeah,
I know God hates the Jag shown.
Remember that a next step.
The under census, everybody throws
handoffs now. You know what I mean?
I just can't
or receive or past five years. I just,
I always get nervous button, the button,
the under funding for if you want to fade,
recency,
just take the under in every game.
I feel like they're there.
They're perhaps maybe an over adjustment
to the totals after that. Everything.
I mean the, the fantasy, everything, the
scoring was just off the charts. Yeah,
it is. It is tough to
bet the under, I mean,
just for the entertainment value alone
to just root against every play to
succeed.
But
I don't think anybody's ever
going to break Emmitt Smith, uh,
time rushing record. They just did. The
opportunities just aren't there anymore.
No.
Yeah, I mean it, it's, I think it's going
to be really hard for any running backs.
The set marks going forward.
Cause I mean,
half their touches are going to be passes.
He's going to be like tech
guy from one the most games,
like whoever won the most
games in MLB history.
So it's like in the 500 it's just like,
it's gonna it's gonna seem that daunting.
Like if there was a different era,
has a head saw,
young hands over
or 800 starts, they're not doing that
anymore. No, they didn't. They, yeah.
I mean they're never going to
come even close to getting there.
Yeah. You pitch your whole
double header. They were men,
they were men,
they were men back then though they had
a stake giants cigar and called it a
little bit of a beer league,
you know? Let's be honest.
Yeah. I mean you look
at Babe Ruth, he does.
He does strike you as your uncle at a
softball game who can just crush it,
who just had a little bit
of hand eye coordination.
Yeah.
I used to play on a softball team when
I was working in a warehouse and they
always had these,
these C's ringers would come out and
they all look built like Babe Ruth,
a little skinny legs,
big beer belly,
and they would just get up and they would
turn that torso and the thing would go
a mile.
Yeah. That's like, I mean that was
Cecil fielder. You know, he was,
he was the modern day version
of that meal. All right.
Next up we got the New York
giants heading down to Dallas.
Right now it's sitting at
a even minus three here.
Both teams started out. Oh, and one
neither. Neither looked great too.
Uh, yeah. I mean, giants
lost at home to the jags.
Cowboys lost on the road to the panthers.
Spill. Which way you lean in the air.
I hate this game. I know. Same here.
This game where it's just like,
like the cowboys at, I
dunno, duct right at home.
It's a deficient to,
the games are always close.
You can never bet against Eli,
but he like,
doesn't seem like it gets
excited until like November,
but they got that running deck,
Eh, Jesus. Am I going to go giants,
giants with Tom Claflin and then I'm going
to go, I think I go be like, I think,
you know, they beat us twice. So I mean,
I see. I got to keep it. These guys,
I'm going to completely different time.
I believe any lie, and I think, uh,
the Dez Bryant hangover and this whole,
whatever the hell they've done,
reef formation of the cowboys is the
hangover lasts for at least three weeks.
I'm going with the giants.
Kramer, I'm, I'm assuming you're going
to be back in your chance as well.
I also believe in Ely.
I appreciate all these mentions of
Tom Coughlin and the Superbowl wins.
And he said how excited Ryan is getting
on the other end of this. But I mean,
here, here's the thing, right? I,
I think I was talking to my dad
today and I was like, I, you know,
I actually wasn't that upset.
The giants played fine.
They played a really good team. Uh,
they played a really good defense.
More importantly, and the offensive
players got theirs. They just,
they were picked six
away. So, uh, but what I,
what they saw in the Dallas cowboys game
was a team that even when Kiki was out
of the game, this team struggled to do
anything. And Dac as we know, Sean Dakota,
Prescott not the best
quarterback in the NFL.
So Eli has historically
played well in Dallas.
I'm going to keep throwing that
out there and yeah, no, of course.
You take the take the giants
before it gets off of three. Yeah.
As much as it pains me,
I'm going to think that I'm going to
take the chance getting three points.
You look at the cowboys, they're
only, they got seek and that's it.
Their offensive line isn't the
dominant force that it was a name.
They have no skill positions to
help deck out, uh, on that office.
I think they're just going to have trouble
putting up points and the giants are
weaknesses. The offensive line, obviously
the jags were able to exploit that.
I don't see the cowboys being able to
get enough pressure on Eli and listen,
it is Sunday night, Sunday night
football. I think your Buddy Odell Ryan,
in spite of the fact that he has not won
a game since he went on the implements
boat trip, I think they
get a victory down in, uh,
down in Dallas stadium there. So I'll
take the giants plus three. I don't feel,
I don't feel great about it because
Dallas coming off at a loss.
Maybe they rally,
but I am just still not a believer in
Jason cared at all as a head coach.
I think Dakota Prescott sounds like some
country singer on one of those American
idol shows. So true. I mean it
just, it's, it cracks me up.
His name's to Dakota vote now for Dakota.
Prescott.
It's the fact that he is also
Prescott. Yeah, you could.
You could beat Dakota something
or something. Prescott,
but did coat up Prescott.
That's a tough one man.
Just like you're just born with an
acoustic guitar and a cowboy hat.
Second you come out.
Yeah. You imagine it's
a, yeah. He's like a,
a chick with a cutoff flannel shirt with
some like short jean shorts coming out
with the acoustic guitar ready to
wow you with their latest rendition.
Well that's another way of looking at it.
I didn't tell him in daisy.
Well he's, he is. He is a woman in my
scenario bill, he's done. He's done.
Sean, let's not forget that Dak
Prescott to, sorry, Dakota's Prescott.
Favorite Song is drops
of Jupiter by train.
That was a little known nugget about
Dakota. That was a trivia fact. We dug up.
All right,
last game of the week that
we'll be breaking down here.
Kansas City chiefs coming off a
nice win on the road against the s,
the Los Angeles chargers.
Now they're heading into Pittsburgh.
Obviously Pittsford coming off that ugly,
ugly tie against the Cleveland
browns right now. My book,
he has the Pittsburgh Steelers as
mine is five favorites at home.
Bill, which way you lean in here? You
know, I didn't see a second of that.
Steel is game. I don't know what,
how was Big Ben Look Looking?
He looked pretty like typical road.
Big Ben like through five what?
Five interceptions? Yeah, I five
interceptions turnovers maybe they know.
I think he, I think he through
maybe four or five pics.
They had six turnovers overall,
but he didn't look good at all.
I like the Steelers at home.
I don't like that number though.
Here's what was picked up. Perfect
number. We just sit on the fence.
Which way am I going to fall?
Uh,
you know what I say the steel is
going to cover the CISA that chiefs,
the chiefs, you know what I mean? Til
they're not the chiefs. So the chiefs,
the Steelers as still the Steelers.
I, I mean, I just thought,
I'm just gonna be like historical bedding
here at the first couple of weeks.
I mean,
I don't know who anybody is at this point.
Well, and I think, you know, talk
about overreaction. Oh my God,
Big Ben was horrible. He's always
been on the road. Oh my God.
They timed the timer.
They tied the browns. Oh,
levy on Bell Big Ben.
He's old school. Take a hit. Like
that guy, you know, he's just,
you know, and he gets it done
in the big moments of the Games.
And I dunno, I, I, I believe
in that guy still. Yeah,
he looks like
he plays well in the home and at home.
And that's why I like this.
Like we're going to fade public perception
that the Steelers stink and we're
gonna fade public perception that the
chiefs are going to win the Superbowl
because, oh my God, Andy Reid
started. Well again. Uh, I mean, look,
this is a classic fade recency
of this line opened at seven.
Sean and people have been crushing
the chief side of this. So wow,
let the number come down. I'm also
going to be on the Steelers, Sean.
I think this is a great kind of
fade recency both ways here. Wow.
I it's going to be a clean sweep are
all in agreeance and all these pics.
I love the Steelers at home
coming off a, I mean, not a loss,
but it may as well be. Then you come
home for their home opener, you know,
they're going to bounce back and then
meanwhile you've got the chief's coming
off a huge road victory to go to the
other side of the country in Pittsburgh.
A home smelling himself like, come
on. Yeah. And we watched that.
We watched that game. Ryan, the, uh,
the chief secondary looked horrible like
there, hey, I don't want
to be a geography snob,
but they're not going to the
other side of the country.
Can't just say to Pittsburgh, that's,
you know, to just into the east coast.
I was, I was factoring in the them
going out to la, then to Kansas City,
then out to Pittsburgh. But yeah, I trash
require traveling teen plane. Come on.
They've got a connection in Poughkeepsie
United in the middle seat. You know,
I think there'll be all right.
They're going to have crib next.
They're not going to,
they're going to be dehydrated.
All those salty peanuts.
I just,
I just think it's a good
spot for Pittsburgh add home
home opener or the Kansas
City defense is just there.
Passing defense in particular is just
horrible and it's a passing league.
I just feel like Pittsburgh is going
to be able to throw all over him.
Anything you say with confidence has,
they're passing the stinks.
I'm not giving you crap here just
after one week. Well,
I'll give you two reasons.
One reason is I watched the game and I
saw that the charger's receivers were
wide open a number of times and just
dropped easy catchable balls and then two
other than that, other
than that, my other,
my other deeper reason is I sit next to
a chiefs fan at work and every day he
opens up his laptop and starts
reading blogs and just goes,
are fucking secondary fucking sucks.
So I'm kind of using that as well.
I'm convinced. So one year
over. All right, Bill,
do a wrap things up here.
You hit with your lock last week you were,
you were two and one with your picks.
The lock of course was that the
sky was falling down or that the,
the announcers would all proclaim
the sky was falling down. Yes.
Hopefully we get that three and
oh this week. But what's your,
what's your lock prediction
for a NFL week too?
Uh,
one person tweets that women should
not be play by play announcers and by
Wednesday, well I guess it's
a, I get another two days.
Somebody is going to say something,
somebody will say something and then
it's going to become this huge thing.
And then I think by this time
next year all play by play.
People will be women. That
would be that. That is my luck.
Lock it up.
Doris Burke will be doing it right.
It's fine. The way as it, as a joke, I was
joking with my buddy going to, I go, dude,
Burt Reynolds died in the play by play
on Monday night. Football is a shemale.
I go, it really is over. We had
a great run. So as, as a joke,
I actually looked up the elks
club going like, I moved.
Just see what the elks club,
that's a men's club or whatever and
looked it up and in 2005 first of all,
I looked it up and the picture was of
a woman. When you go to the website,
they sued in 2005 and one so like even
they've even infiltrated obviously the,
I mean arguably the biggest group
of jerk off men in the country.
I mean you're literally talking to take
away like the hats with the little tasks
and it's hilarious. Like I looked it up.
I would never join it, but I was just,
I just,
it was going to get a check out of the
fact if there was one place left where
you could just chill out and not
have to adjust your behavior.
And the old gentleman, he's over, man.
It was the elks club and Augusta
national and then both those have been
infiltrated. They're now no
longer all male. All right.
We had a hell of a Ron Dude. Yeah,
man. Really did have a hell of a run.
Every dynasty must come to an end.
Tens of thousands of years I think.
Drawing Emmett and the Herman.
The triplets.
Yeah. We were a three headed
monster for a long time.
Well, this is, a lot of people are
saying this is a rebuilding year for men.
You know,
we're,
we're hoping to get the number one
traffic took a lot of heat loss.
A lot of lost a lot. I took a
lot of Ellis out there. Yeah.
We're going to try to forget about
last year. And, uh, you know,
we're going to hit reset. We've got Jon
Gruden back. He's back at different times,
so much. Jon Gruden face. I
can't wait. Oh Man. It was,
he was loved seeing him back then.
It was so funny how like,
he was just kind of a different
guy in the broadcast booth.
And then the second he put
the headphones back on again.
He just wanted a break back to the
chuck you faced. I loved it. Yeah.
The thing that was frustrating about
him as an announcer was that clearly he
thought about getting back into coaching
so he wouldn't bad mouth guys on the
air. And he just loved everyone at,
he's a great guy. Look at this guy.
And then as soon as he's
got that headset on,
you could just see him
screaming and yelling. He was,
he was just so pissed at cars. He
got the job. He cut half the team.
Uh, I thought you said you love me.
I, Hey, the broadcast booth. Yeah.
None of the claim. Yeah. All right.
Well see how we do, gentlemen, uh,
I'm going to get more bold with my
predictions is once, you know, hopefully,
you know,
what am I actually,
my show's got moved this weekend
because of the hurricane,
which hopefully goes out to see a am I
supposed to work in Virginia and South
Carolina. So I'm hoping
that, you know, you know,
a lot of those people are probably still
upside down in their houses because the
piece of shit bankers,
so the last thing they need is a hurricane
to hit the house that's not going to
be worth more than what they owe on it.
Screwed by the insurance
companies as well. Yes. Yeah.
For the trisector. So, um,
uh,
that's what I'm thinking about this week.
I'm supposed to be there the following me,
but I,
but the other side was I will be home
and didn't have enough time to watch the
game. So hopefully a silver lining
in that shout out to Dakota Prescott.
Love it.
All right.
And obviously a checkout Bellbird outcome
for all the upcoming tour information.
And of course, uh, check
out my book e. Dot.
Ag Promo code fill beds for that a
hundred percent deposit bonus play.
When I get paid my bookie that AGL?
Yeah Buddy.
That's his.
Hey, what's going on? It's Belper
and it is the Monday morning podcast.
Monday,
September 13th,
2010 what's going on? How
are you? You're feeling good.
I'm going to try to pretend like am I
actually went out drinking last night and
a little banged up. A little banged up.
It's actually 10 oh one east coast time.
I'm in New York City. This is a the
biggest week of the year for me.
I'm back here doing press for my
new one hour special. Let it go.
That comes out in premiers. They
switched the date on me. It is now.
It's Sunday,
September 19th at 11:00 PM so,
uh,
please tune in. Please
listen, please watch.
Please invite other people over.
Why don't you have a little
fucking standup comedy
party? Don't they have those?
They have super bowl parties.
You know,
we invite a bunch of broads over and
they talked during the game and they shut
up during the commercials.
I kind of liked that one.
How much do you think that
that one Costa did? Um,
anyways,
yeah.
So I'm in town this week and I'm going
to be doing the opion Anthony Program,
my fucking favorite. Um,
I'm going to be doing that.
I believe I'm going to be doing
something on the versus network.
I am going to be talking to anybody with
the microphone this week, doing my gosh,
darndest to try and get people to
listen to my fucking podcasts. But, uh,
how many podcasts see what happens when
I multitask to get people to watch my
special.
And um,
I'm gonna apologize for the lack of funny
up until this point already right out
of the fucking gate just because I have
to make sure I get this information out
at the beginning of the podcast.
All right,
so my special September 19th
at 11:00 PM on comedy central.
Um, please go ahead and watch it.
And if you want to preorder my DVD,
look into your heart.
If you want to order this thing
for an unbelievably, ridiculously,
almost an embarrassingly low price,
you can order the fucking thing for like
$13 in like 29 cents on amazon.com I
don't know how the fuck they
came up with that price,
but I got to admit I felt a
little insulted. You know,
why don't you just fucking give it away?
amazon.com
so there you go.
Why don't you buy to look at that?
Because right after that it's going to
be 1999 so then if you actually go out
and buy two then if you come out
to my show, you'd be like, Dude,
stop bitching about your free fucking
podcast because I actually bought two your
DVDs and I'll be thinking in my
head, wow, this guy dropped 40 bucks.
What a good shit.
And you'll be laughing because in
the back of your head you're like,
actually I dropped 26 and change,
you know,
26 and change. I mean, what can you,
what can you get to have
for $26 I can get gum,
get two packs of gum. Actually
probably get a lot more than that.
Of course you go to footlocker and those
fucking tee shirts you can get like,
what can you get? Like, like
58 tee shirts at footlocker?
Is that Michael Moore's next movie?
If I was Michael Moore and I was going,
what the fuck should
out in the next movie?
Should I make about how poor people
are sad and rich people are evil?
I would try and find who
are the people who may, who?
Oh, these people, they
make the Mug a teacher.
Um,
you know,
how do they give you fucking
like nine t shirts for $18?
How do they do that?
Um, you know what, this is, I'm
not even hung over, but I just,
I rather than being hung over,
which I should have been,
but I wasn't, but I'm not,
whatever I'm trying to say, I just woke
up with just weird music in my head.
You have to do that. You wake
up, you drank last night,
you dot hung over. But he's,
you just wake up and then you just
singing some song that you haven't even
thought of for years. I was
just walking around my, my uh,
fucking apartment here, just walking
around and going some like it hot,
some like it hot bump,
bump, bump, bump, bump,
bump up about the CPAP
and then how it goes.
Feel the heat
burning into the knife or the night,
whatever the fuck it is.
Is that Robert Palmer?
Some like it hot. Ooh. Robert Palmer.
Tell us about your new sexy,
sultry,
single with that hot Latino
beat underneath it. Well,
I had recently gone to Cuba and I are
inserted a fucking go Cohiba and to some
fucking prostitutes or fish.
And I was just really a overwhelmed by
the culture down there and she fucking
hate that.
You know what I make whenever,
like the White Star tries to have some
sort of ethnic beat under their music and
then they always get to talk about some
trip that they took to Swahili and how
when they were sitting
there in that Walden resort,
they somehow fuckin absorbed the culture.
You know,
you guys haven't gone down
to the Caribbean, you gone
down into the Caribbean,
however the fuck you say it. Some people
say Caribbean, some people say Caribbean,
but to me it's,
it's all one beautiful universe.
The guys went down to the
Caribbean to go scuba diving,
to be nose to nose with
a fucking Barracuda.
They get barracudas down there quick.
Why don't you look it up and then send
me an email and tell me how fucking
uninformed I
actually, Barracuda are indigenous
to this Egil for Brazil.
The fuck up. I can look this shit up
to, what is it? A freshwater fish?
If you go down to like fucking Uruguay,
can you get a Barracuda Sandwich?
You know, just to start your day
rather than, than getting like a bacon,
egg and cheese.
Did they do that and do
they use the whole fish?
Because they're better than Americans
where we would just like use like just the
best part of the fish and then the rest
we would just sort of throw out the
window,
just toss it back into the ocean and
it gets all hooked up with like old
rollerblades and fucking, um, those shoes.
Every guy war in the late nineties,
remember those fucking shoe.
So slip on shoes that sorta look like
sneakers. Canada, look like shoes.
Remember those? Fuck it. Thanks.
Where are all those right now?
I'll tell you where they are.
They're floating out in the
middle of the Pacific Ocean,
getting broken down in the sunlight.
Right?
And then some dolphin inhales it
and then you go out to Japan. Right?
And they don't give a fuck about dolphins.
You guys see the cove?
Okay.
You know they'll fucking
Dolphin Schindler's list.
Basically. I couldn't eat. I just
heard what that movie was about.
And I fucking love animals so much that
I couldn't eat. I couldn't even know.
Schindler's list actually had
somebody fucking decent in it,
trying to help out those being
slaughtered. Ow. What the fuck am I?
I didn't even see the goddamn movie.
All I heard was a bunch of people,
they drive these dolphins
into this fucking cove and
then they just beat him to
death.
And it was a
okay,
it, it was so fun just to
hear. It was so fucking sad.
And then it just made me so God damn
angry that I like, you know what?
I'm not going to fuck,
I'm not gonna, you know,
I'm not gonna Watch that stuff
is what am I going to do? Oh,
who got himself to treat at
the local Deli. This is what,
this is how you get out
of shape in New York,
even though you walk around all the time
is you just walk into a Deli and you're
like, you know what? I'm
going to start my day.
We're on our way to the perfect place, the
perfect place. Bup, Bup, bup, bup, bup,
bup, bup, Ba. That's another fucking song.
Just popped in my head. What is that from?
It's the perfect place.
Okay.
Was that, that was like a
Hanna Barbera cartoon. Ron.
Our way to the perfect place.
The perfect place. Anyways,
I'm sorry. This is like,
I have weird hangovers sometimes
I don't have a headache. I just,
just music pops into my head.
Sound like it. Hot sound like it.
Um, anyways, some white
guy playing yoga blocks.
Does that sound Latino? Speaking
of Latino, I went into, well,
one of these little fucking Bodega's
[inaudible] La dawn day as,
uh,
the fucking orange juicer.
Um,
I was up there and I got myself an Oj and
a banana because I'm really into these
light breakfast.
His now.
I finally realized that when you wake
up and you have a lumberjack breakfast,
that seriously, it's like I've been saying
on this podcast, it's like getting up.
It's like if you just woke up the second
you woke up and you just sprinted 400
yards without stretching or anything,
didn't even put on your fucking shoes.
He just ran down the street.
I buy, buy, buy, buy, buy on
the fucking pebbles. Right.
That's what you're doing to your body.
That's why I started slow.
I get a little fucking corn based orange
juice according to food inc it's all
corn now. Excuse me. And then
I have a banana, you know,
which is like sort of like a
baby food in a phallic form.
That's what it's like.
It's like a big fucking, uh, would
have a big yellow dick. One animal.
I got fucking Porno,
Star Canary if you want it to.
That's what it bananas like.
Right. So typical New York,
I'm trying to eat healthy.
And then I look over and I see these
two little toasted balls to add to the
fucking, the, the, the,
the canary thing, right?
Like they lopped off
this fucking Porto nuts.
And I looked at the lady and I
was like, oh, La, San your retail,
what the fuck are those? And
she's like, oh, those are,
those are coconut balls. And I
was like, get the fuck Outta here.
And she says, I can't get the fuck outta
here. I have to work. And I said, no,
I didn't mean it. Literally. I
meant get the fuck Outta here.
Those are made out of coconut.
And she said, see? And I was like,
I fucking love coconut, you know?
And she started laughing like,
I never said you didn't fuck. Oh, do
you want them? And I'm like, absolutely.
I want them to know I have him.
So I have to tell on you guys.
I was going to begin my day with a,
you know,
we didn't really healthy. I ended up
grabbing two sugar balls. Actually,
the call, uh, I actually
hear the Coco Komodo
and underneath an English macaroon
coconut. Here's the ingredients, sugar,
coconut,
and then in parentheses says may contain
sodium metaphor wholesale such harsh
for whiteness.
I love that shit.
Like how much did they not even research?
What the fuck is? Yeah, it might.
It might,
might have a little bit of this
met up by sulfite for whiteness.
Well, the coconuts white. Why
would you need to add to that?
Is this some coconut that you fucking
had in a warehouse for years? Egg Whites,
invert sugar,
corn Syrup and salt.
So for the most part it's all natural
except for the sodium metapod by said vice
types of light for whiteness.
And I'm gonna try one. Let's see.
Sweet Dreams are made of the keys.
How bad his fucking Annie Lennox.
When you think of the annals of
the fucking baddest rock chicks,
we'll start with white chicks,
right? We'll move all the way around.
We'll start with the baddest
white chicks of all time.
I would say fuck an Annie Lennox
and no particular order here.
If I was rolling stone,
I do an entire issue of this.
The hundreds greatest rock chicks of
all time rolling stone really is clearly
showing people if he haven't
been paying attention.
How few people buying magazines now?
Oh,
that fucking listening to discussion.
It's like a donut. Oh,
it's gross. I was too much.
That's fucking disgusting.
I have to take another bite.
Cause now my sugars shot
and arise right now.
I'm craving it. Ah Fuck Man. I
need another hit man. Oh yeah.
Oh I stand corrected.
These are fucking delicious to eat.
The first bite.
Is your body going? No, don't
do it. So it tastes like shit.
But then that sugar gets in your
veins and it's like, come on man.
You know you want it and
then you just keep going.
Like this is really rude to be eating
on the mic. All right. Annie Lennox,
you know, and then can't even think now.
Any Linux, the chick from the
pretenders, Chrissy Hine, right
Pat Benatar.
Now that's not what I
want it. I, you know,
I always got confused with the
chick from the runaways, Joan Jett,
Joan jets, Shit. Um, and she's still hot.
Damn it. Those are fucking delicious. Ah,
not after a swig of Oj though, rose. Okay.
They're really hard to chew.
Wow. What am I fucking neighbors
just here. Just heard that.
Wondering what the fuck I'm talking about?
Um,
all right. Sorry. Sorry. You know
what? I'm actually last night.
Um, no, finish your fucking thought
bill. If you look at rolling stone,
they used to be this big magazine.
Just I'm talking about when you held it,
it was used to be like
the fucking third bigger.
Now they've shrunk it down to, it's
like a third of the size it used to be.
And now every other month they're
doing those, those list things.
100 greatest guitarists of all time.
The hundred greatest
tambourine players of all time.
Right now they have the hundred greatest
Beatles songs of all time. It's like,
did they even write a hundred songs?
You know,
they just do that so
people can, you know, they,
I guess people always buy those magazines
and they go, Ooh, too, fuck, oh,
can you put,
oh hey bulldog in front of
while my guitar gently weeps.
And then people write notes.
Was that really worth revisiting?
I don't think it was.
Well those are my top three,
top three fucking white chick
rock singers of all time. And um,
well considering we've been
talking so much about Latino's,
let's go with top three Latinos
of all time, Latinos singers.
And this is when my whiteness is going
to come to see if I can even name three.
Uh, Salina. They did a
movie about her, Selena,
Jennifer Lopez and um,
ah, fuck. This is embarrassing.
Lucille Ball.
Okay.
And Lucille Ball. Fuck you. She
was made to Ricky Ricardo, Bam.
Those are your three. But she never
really sang did she? What the fuck I know.
I know more than that. Celine.
I don't even know any songs.
Selena sank.
Okay.
I just know she had a psycho fan.
That's all I know.
And then Jennifer Lopez plater oh wait,
wait.
The chick from Miami sound machine,
right?
What songs today saying, Ooh, my Amie,
we're fuck and taken over.
What songs did they sing?
I saw that fucking band stunk.
Miami sound machine,
all that fucking turquoise with all that.
That just when I pictured them,
I just was a bunch of
people in puffy pants.
Okay.
And they had like 58 people on percussion
and unlike one keyboard and then she
was skipping around in her boots,
right?
Isn't that wasn't it what Miami sound
machine was the fuck songs? Did they say,
God damn it.
I used to know all of this shit.
I can't get that Robert Palmer shit
out of my head anyways, whatever.
So I want to learn some,
tell me,
give me your top three Latino
fucking singers of all time.
I know somebody already compiling a
list and getting pissed at me because I
don't know what the
fuck I'm talking about,
but that's what people do on this
podcast. Mike, last week I made a,
I made a reference to the Pullman
strike when I was reading about a Grover
Cleveland or some shit like that
and this guy wrote, he wrote, Hey,
uninformed bill.
The reason they brought the military in
during the Pullman strike was because
the workers in quotes, he
puts, we're becoming violent,
not because they were striking because
they were attacking the alternate workers
brought in to fill the void of
labour caused by the strike.
And this is hilarious.
The guy writes down his name,
marketing and business
development coordinator.
Yet you sound like the guy who would
side with the fucking people who,
who are underpaying. It's first of
all, why do you put workers in in uh,
okay.
In parentheses.
You know what I mean?
The strike was because the
workers were becoming violent.
Not because they were striking
because they were attacking the,
the scabs they brought
into to take their jobs.
That's part of a strike yet dumb
fuck. You know, and you know,
I love to sir,
is the way you're acting as though you
had even heard of the Pullman strike
before I said it.
That's that classic Internet Shit.
We don't have to go to
the library anymore.
He just look up the Pullman strike and
then you read two paragraphs and then
you're like, oh actually, you know what
the reason you're just as dumb as me sir.
Of course they attack the scab workers
brought him cause now they're going to be
out of out of a job. And
that was my point. And who
does the military side with?
Okay.
The military works for the
fucking rich people. All right.
And if you don't fucking believe that,
that I'm not going to eat
another fucking coconut ball.
Okay.
Oh, it just gets better. No, it doesn't.
All right, that's enough of that.
Jesus Christ. Jesus. All right,
let's talk NFL football. Everybody. Oh,
before I do the FM podcast.com,
everybody, um, I made a video on there,
um,
where I did a little tour of the comedy
store analysis stood outside the comedy
store and I talk shit about some of
the people walking by down the street.
If you guys want to check it out, go
to the [inaudible] podcast.com. Um,
the official,
the one and only the only one there
is the official fan page of the Monday
morning podcast.
And I also want to thank everybody who
went out and bought the Oh gene ringtone
last week. All right. I uh,
was very impressed with the
amount of people that, uh,
that debt went ahead and bought the a
ringtone. If you didn't listen last week,
I have a new ring tone.
It all costs us 99 cents and um,
you know,
that way I don't have to really charge
for the fucking podcast and it's also a,
um,
yeah,
it's not required if you want to do
what you can. If you don't, you don't,
it's no big deal. And uh, we have
all the instructions up there.
If you have an iPhone, it goes right onto
your phone. If you have a blackberry,
there's like one little thing
you have to do with something,
but they have all the instructions on
the m and podcast on how to upload it to
your phone. And, um,
okay.
You know, we just want to thank everybody
for being patient, uh, for a couple of,
took a couple of days to explain it to,
to get the information out there.
So I wanted to thank you guys,
but shipping it seriously means a lot
to me that people actually went out and
supported the podcasts like that. So
thank you. From the bottom of my heart.
And the gentleman who runs the [inaudible]
podcast.com. All right. And with that
bump up,
it's time to talk about NFL football here.
Um,
I actually was flying on a
plane during the Patriots game,
so I can't really talk too much about it.
Other than that, I just, I was watching,
I actually had satellite TV on, on the, on
the plane. So I was sitting there going,
ah, fuck, I'm gonna miss the fucking game.
And then I see that they're going to have
satellite TV and I got excited. Oh boy.
Oh boy. Right. And I fucking turn
it on and all I get, I had NBC.
Okay.
And then the rest were like
discovery animal planet,
and then they had three ESPN.
So I'm praying how I hope
and pray that I will,
but today I am still just
a bill. Um, fuck you.
The songs are in my head
because I'm hung over.
I'm praying that the Patriots
game was going to be NBC.
And
it turned out that not only
was the game not on NBC,
they didn't even have
a football game on NBC.
They had some fucking
infomercial on insults.
So I was like, you gotta be
fucking kidding me. Right?
You gotta be fucking kidding me. And,
uh, so then I, I just was watching ESPN.
I was watching all the college football
games that I already watched. Uh,
I think Michigan's back everybody.
Okay.
Hail to the victors value at
hail to the vector at Bat.
Bat Bat,
Pat, Pat, Pat, Pat, Pat, Pat,
Pat, Pat, Pat, Pat,
Pat, Pat, Pat, Pat, pat.
Do you wanna just sit there?
I did three fucking college songs and
they all sound the exact fucking same hail
to the victors. Wake up
the echoes and fucking, uh,
the Fleetwood Mac Trojan band.
It's all, all the same shit.
I'm anyways, yes, I watched
that and I watch the, uh,
the USA basketball game against a Turkey.
That was the shit.
And uh, we won that
championship. But anyways,
I was watching the ticker and by the way,
what's his face there is going
to be the next superstar.
And I saw him when he played in Seattle
and I can't even remember his fucking
name already cause I'm
that fucking hung over.
Come on brain work for me
because with a d I can't fucking remember,
but he was a Shitty,
he was hitting fall away.
Three pointers as a six,
10 I even what position you play?
I don't know.
I don't know shit about basketball.
All right, let's plow ahead here. Um,
patriots won the cults lost, so I'm
excited, right? I was also excited.
How about Detroit? How about Cleveland?
Come on, you guys. You got to admit,
you know, you had a little bit, uh,
I think, I think that does this, uh,
a ray of light. I didn't see any
either one of those fucking gains,
but I was just,
I was just watching the ticker and um,
I saw that that dude from out play
for cow best had two touchdowns.
Right. And Cleveland was basically one in
the fucking game right down to the end.
I know I'm not trying to talk down to
you guys, but I'm just saying, you know,
whatever your beat Miami, that's got
to feel good luck. You know what?
The main reason why I'm
bringing this shit up is,
is because I want to say the shit before
the fucking game comes out tonight.
I got 50 bucks on the ravens tonight.
Straight up. I bet at straight up.
Even though the jets are favored by
like six, I don't know what the line is,
but I was like, you know what? You can
keep your fucking points there, missy.
I don't give a shit.
That's how confident I am.
How fucking dumb or the New York jets,
what did they,
can you just,
can somebody explain to me the strategy
of pissing off every fucking every team
in the league? Yeah. First of all,
I love it being a patriots fan because
for the first time in 10 fucking years,
nobody was talking about bill Bellacheck.
Nobody was talking about the Patriots.
Nobody was talking about Tom Brady.
Rarely.
The guy even got into a
fucking car accident and that
was barely a fucking story
compared to the shit storm that is
going on with the New York jets.
What? What do they doing? Let
me ask you guys a question.
How amped up does Ray Lewis get
before a football game when,
when the other team hasn't
talked shit about them?
I think they're out of their
fucking minds. Ray Lewis,
I put it on my Facebook page.
That's my prediction.
He is going to rip Sanchez his
fucking head off tonight. Sanchez.
This guy who everybody,
for some reason they're forgetting the
up and down season that he had last year
and they're, they're acting like
they have this proven quarterback.
I don't get it, man. And they went out
and they drafted all, they got signed,
all these free agents.
They're really reminded me of the
University of Miami when they got off the
plane wearing the fatigues and
they were talking all this shit.
And then when it came down
to it, they didn't fucking
win anything. Remember that?
Or like the,
the Los Angeles Lakers when they added
Gary Payton and Karl Malone and you're
thinking, how can they not fucking,
and then they didn't, I don't,
I don't get it that that year when the
Patriots went undefeated in the regular
season and then get their asses kicked in,
in the super bowl by the giants,
it's like the hype was so fucking
big that from November on,
we were playing playoff games.
Teams were coming in so fucking
amped up to kick the shit out of us.
It just wore,
it wore us down.
It was down to me while no one's
paying attention to the giants,
to the point that giants put up like 35
points and the last week of the season
against us.
And for some reason we was still 14 point
favorites three fucking weeks later to
this day I kicked myself for
not taking that bet. And, uh,
yeah,
it was ridiculous.
And meanwhile the giants had
beaten Tampa Bay in Tampa Bay.
They beat Dallas in Dallas.
They beat Green Bay and Green Bay and
no one's paying attention to them.
Then everybody sat there with
their jaws in the ground.
They kicked this didn't even kick the
shit out of us. They just beat us like,
holy fuck.
How did this team that beat three awesome
teams and their own fucking building
come in and beat us?
[inaudible] it's fucking ridiculous.
So the jets have started their season at
zero and zero with the whole league as
amped up the kick the shit out of them
as people were amped up to beat the
fucking patriots it by mid November.
All right,
and I'm telling you right now, they are
going to have a mediocre fucking season.
I think it's going to start
off with the loss tonight.
I'm not saying that they're not going
to go nine and seven, but these guys,
I don't know what the fucking problem is
and not to mention that now they have a
nice little scandal here. Cover the
daily news. They says cool. Your jets,
TV reporters, flags team
for Lewd behavior, um,
in his saints,
reporter for Azteca TV.
Where the fuck is that broadcast?
It's is at the center of a jet Brouhaha.
Basically, if you see this girl,
she's fucking hottie right?
She's got her little pass here and uh,
you know,
she's got some Cleveland show.
Oh my God. Are you serious?
They got a picture of
her edit jets practice.
She's got on the tightest fucking jeans
I've ever seen in my life with the most
perfect round ass you've ever seen.
And she's in high heels.
Okay.
And she's walking around a bunch of
football players who got that testosterone
going with a fat shit talk and coach,
let me guess.
Somebody said something out of
line. Oh, this is just, this is,
you know what I mean?
This right here,
and this is one of these
things where you can't say,
well look how you're dressed. Cause
they go, you're blaming the victim.
She should have a right to have three
quarters ever tents outside of her shirt
with a thong going up
her fucking ass crack.
And she should be allowed to walk into
a locker room with a bunch of football
players and not have one out of fucking
whatever the fuck you're going to say.
Well,
one fucking rude comic gimme a break.
Nfl boss Roger Goodell was demanding
answers last night from jets players.
But why don't you look at
the pictures, Roger? Huh?
What are you a fucking unit? You don't
understand what the problem was. Uh,
for players,
coaches accused of subjecting of female
sports reporter to sexist locker room
conduct, they should've just said for
subjecting her to lock a rum conduct.
This is basically what happened.
She went into a locker room and was
subjected to locker room conduct.
Can you believe it?
I remember last night when I went out
to a bar and I was subjected to bar room
conduct. I couldn't
believe it. I was like,
what am I in a bar or something as they
prepare for their season opener tonight,
gang green is dealing with the burgeoning
scandal over the treatment of Inez
Saints, uh, for Azteca of
Mexico. This girl is a 10.
She's fucking smoking gorgeous Emmy.
You got to see the way she's dressed.
Okay.
And Fuck you ladies. Fuck you. Look at
the way she's dressed. She's one of those,
you know what's funny about the broads
out there is this is the kind of girl,
right? The kind of woman that kind
of fucking who, uh, who, if you know,
if any of these women,
you know who will listen to his podcast,
they're walking down the street with
their husband and this girl comes walking
by, they immediately, they
date fucking, you know,
in the eyes become like little
slits. Is He looking at me? You know,
and then they're looking at their husband
and they're going to get mad at you
because this other bitch goes to the gym.
You know,
like somehow it's your fucking fault
and they fucking looking at you because
they can't just come out and say, oh
my God, that girl is fucking gorgeous.
I'm so jealous her, they, they
can't, they can't own that emotion.
So then they look at you and they're
just waiting for you to glance and that
part and that woman's direction.
So they can blame you that just fuck
another girl is eating right and and
fucking doing herself up right?
It's going to become your fucking fault.
I used to do a bit about that.
Next time you, you know what?
Here's one for you guys on a burn.
A joke right here that I
never fucking recorded.
So who gives a shit next time you're
walking down the street with your
girlfriend,
right in this fucking unbelievably
smoking shit comes walking up the street,
right? And what do you got? And she
immediately just looks at you like,
go ahead and look at her so I can take
out my fucking hatred of this better
looking girl and make it your fucking
fault, right? This is what you do.
Rather than trying to look away
and having blood come out of your,
out of your eyes, you try not to
look at this fucking hot piece.
Hey should coming up the street.
What you do is you fucking point right
at her and whatever she's wearing,
you tell your girl that she'd
looked great in that you point read.
Then it'd be like, you know what? You'd
look great in a dress like that, right?
And then immediately just a p, you
know, it, it makes their insecurity go,
oh my God. Really? Do you think I could
get away with wearing something day?
Totally used to girls feeling good.
You're staring at the girl's ass.
You're talking about the cut of the dress.
It's bullshit.
You're checking around without
disrespecting a woman. See right there.
Bill burr bringing couples together.
All right, let's continue on here. Um,
so this woman, 32 years old, 32 years old,
still in smoking fucking shape of former
Miss Universe contestant complained.
She was bombarded with cat calls
and boarish antics at the jets,
New Jersey training facility to the
extent she wanted to. And in quotes said,
cover my ears. Um, dying of embarrassment.
This woman,
right?
Former Miss Universe contestant who
would walk on stage with a fucking string
bikini and high heels with a hoo ha
hanging out talking about how to save
Greenland or whatever is
embarrassed because she walked
around. I mean, give me a,
you know what I mean?
This is why women stink.
It's like, what are you
doing there? To begin with.
It's a bunch of guys playing football.
It's like,
and then we're cool enough to let you in
there and then everybody has to fucking
adjust their behavior because your,
their wig scares me.
Scares me. There's a lady
present. You know what I mean?
And you'll wonder why you get
called a cunt. That's why.
Right fucking there.
It's just fucking unbelievable.
I would never walk into a god damn baby
shower and be, oh, excuse me. Excuse me.
There's a guide present.
Can we put a fucking
game on Ovia I wouldn't,
I'd be standing in the corner going, oh
Geez, when is this Shit gonna be over?
But I wouldn't at any point try to cock
block what anybody was fucking talking
about.
Go and talk about sex in the city.
Talk about your favorite shoes or whatever
the fuck it is you do. I wouldn't,
okay.
Be covering my ears.
Dying of embarrassment.
If you all started talking about
my package, I'd be flattered.
Um, this is some of the
more, more ignorant shit that
I've said on this podcast,
but I think there's a point behind this.
Let's continue with the article.
MMM,
good. Al. It's just said,
I'm dying of embarrassment.
Saints tweeted in Spanish,
um,
Goodell immediately ordered
an investigation into the
troubling in air quotes,
allegations, which were addressed
in a team meeting last night. Uh,
this meeting is now called to order,
uh,
last night when that smoking hot chick
with the tight clothes came in and
everybody said, God Damn, look
at that fucking ass. Yeah,
you're not allowed to do that.
Uh, excuse me, coach. Ah,
yeah. Yes sir. Yeah, we,
you talking about that
girl who came in and,
and Teddy's way hanging out of her
shirt? Yeah, that one. Yeah, that one.
We a disrespected her.
See, this is, this is the deal.
All right. They come down,
they want the fucking attention. You
know what? Wait, what? What is she,
what is she doing in the fucking
locker room to begin with?
You know what? She even in the locker
room, did I even, they even say that,
I can't remember. Didn't you see any given
Sunday? You don't remember that movie?
You're going to stand there and there's
gonna be some black dude with a dick
down to the floor. I mean, why are
you going in? I wouldn't go in there
if I went in there,
they'd start giving me cat calls.
Like I was that fresh fish guy when the
beginning of shots, Shawshank redemption.
Okay.
And I'd be dying of embarrassment too, but
I'd fucking take it. It'd be like, yeah,
well what the fuck did you think was
going to happen? You're a fucking pansy.
And he'd come walking
into an NFL locker room.
They're all going to give you
shit and say you're a pussy,
right?
I mean, what kind of a fucking
world are we living in now?
When a gorgeous woman wearing tight,
ridiculous clothes is going to walk into
a fucking at a football practice and
she's going to get upset, that's that
she got unwanted attention. Well,
why don't you come there and dress
like they did in the 18 hundreds
with one of their big hoop skirts and
they can't see you fucking thighs.
This chick is fucking ridiculous.
Look,
look at the New York Daily News and look
at the little inset picture that they
have of her. I'm sure they did it for
a fucking reason. It's ridiculous.
Look at that fucking ass. Look at,
that's the first thing I think.
Look at that fucking ass. Jesus
Christ. And then she's holding a mic.
It looks like a dick in her hand while
she bobbing her head up and down and she
asked a questions.
This is like entrapment.
Yeah.
Anyways, let's fucking
continue. Um, but, but papa,
we've had contact with the team multiple
times and are moving very aggressively
to establish the facts.
The NFL spokesman, Greg,
I Hilo said jets owner woody Johnson
woke up from his coma and said,
oh, wait, that guy none off.
That guy is actually young, uh,
called saints to hear his side of the
story and said that the team will take any
appropriate steps necessary to maintain
a respectful environment for the media.
Basically,
this girl is now going to become a
fucking millionaire off of this lawsuit
because she walked to an NFL practice
with her Miss Universe body with tight
fucking clothes on. And
somebody said, God Damn,
look at that fucking ass right there.
Hey mark.
What the fuck would you do with dad?
I fucking bedroom over fucking
table and then fucking rex. Ryan.
I can't even see him. My fucking
my fucking stomach. So big. Huh?
Was that a good one? Players. Do you
guys like me? I talk just like you.
I can't wait for them
to fucking lose tonight.
They're going to get their fucking asses
kicked and I can get their asses kicked
butt. They're going to
lose. They're going to lose,
and then they're going to
have a short week. All right,
and guess who's back the
New England patriots? Huh?
38 fucking points up
against. Oh, chose Sinco.
Tarell Owens. Cade McNabb down.
What's the name of your quarterback?
Something. Wilson. I don't even know
the name of your fucking quarterback.
He was awesome.
And then he got hurt.
He's actually a good quarterback
with the fuck's his name.
I know it's not caving now.
Ucla fucking Heisman trophy winner.
Classic Chicago Bear
quarterback drug draft.
They love Kate Mcdowell and they loved
the Rex Grossman. For some reason,
they didn't like Doug Flutie. Let's keep,
let's ship him out of there. Really,
you want to ship a proven winner out?
Absolutely.
We don't want him around here
leading the team to victories.
Where the fuck is the Goddamn
patriots game here? Oh, Carson Palmer.
This is what I love about that man.
He was 34 50 for 345 yards. Oh,
chose Sinco had 12 catches for 159 yards.
All right.
Yet they only scored 24 fucking points.
You know my buddy was saying it, they
getting back to that bend but don't break.
You know, someone else was telling me
Bella check is doing the defense again,
which is his fucking, that's,
that's what he does. I Dunno.
I have a, I have high hopes, but you know,
it's not about the patriots this year.
It's all about the j e t s jets, jets,
jets. Right. Running the fucking yaps.
You wanted the attention. Now you
got it. Oh, I can't fucking wait.
You guys looked up to stats of
that fucking Joe Flacco. Joe Falco,
whatever the fuck his name is.
I didn't know what his name is.
All I know is they raped us
last year in the playoffs.
You got ray rice is going to be running
all over you fucking cunts. Huh?
What do you think? Cause you got
that old guy from the dolphins,
that good looking son of a bitch.
You should be doing fucking underwear
ads like Jim Palmer. That's the guy.
That's the guy that's
going to stop everybody.
That dude has been showing
up late to practice.
Rex Ryan is making a joke out of it
because he has such a fucking need to be
liked by his own God damn players.
You wait,
you wait till the fucking wheels fall
off. All right, here's a contest I want.
I want to introduce here.
How bout
whoever guesses which week?
Rex Ryan's going to fucking
cry first after which game.
If you pick it right,
I'm going to send you an autographed copy
of my new fucking DVD. So there you go.
People, you got fucking 17 weeks to
pick when actually not this week,
16 weeks.
I'm including the bye week.
The first week he's going to start fucking
crying because somebody criticized,
you know, somebody stole his m and m
flavored fucking ice cream. All right.
Enough of this shit. That's
my thing. I got 50 bucks,
50 bucks in the Ravens and I'm confident.
I'm confident that not only I didn't
even take the spread straight up.
Can you tell,
I don't know what else to talk about.
I just keep saying over and
over again what my bed is.
Let's talk about depression, shall
we? Speaking of fucking Rex Ryan, um,
somebody sent me a long email here
that should eat up some time. Um,
I actually did,
I tell you guys last night,
we actually recorded me and to Rosa got
fucking hammered last night and we were
like, you know, we should do, we should
go home and record a drunk, uninformed.
And I'm like, well I have to do the
Monday morning podcast. He goes,
we'll fucking do that too.
So last night for an hour in a half as
we sat there drinking and getting even
more drunk, drunk, horror, whatever
the fucking word is, we recorded,
we talked for at least an hour and a half.
The record is shut off at an hour and
15 fucking minutes and you just hear us
get progressively more and more
drunk. Uh, I listened to it.
There's a lot of funny moments, but it's
just way too long. So I am going to,
I'm going to edit it, I'm going
to dice it up and I'll, I'll,
I'll put together a greatest hits of
it. They got that coming up, but I just,
it was just too much self sabotage.
It's like I got my special
coming out this week.
I really had to make sure I hyped it
and I completely was not hyping it in a,
in a great way. Uh, you know,
it was just that it was bad,
it was bad and there was a lot of,
uh,
embarrassing moments and you
know, I, you know, I'm just,
I'm going to edit it people, that's
what I'm trying to say. All right,
go fuck yourselves. And not
putting it all up. All right.
Youtube videos of the week.
A fat kid goes insane after
getting air horn in the face.
Try to guess what that one's about. Fat
Kid goes insane after getting air horn,
air horn in the face. Ed,
uh, this kid, his face,
he looks like, if, if precious
was a white eight year old,
just picture that face. That's what
this kid looks like. All right.
Here's what I'm sure everybody
saw us says face verse watermelon.
This is somebody on the amazing race.
It took a sling shot and shot a
watermelon on a fucking candle up.
I don't know what it was, and it came
back and blast her right in the face.
It's absolutely hilarious.
They
actually showed it on ESPN.
They did the top 10 funny sports moments
of the week and hers was number one.
And you know what they
did because she's abroad.
What they had to do was they put,
you know,
you know when they had the list of shit
that they're going to talk about coming
up on the right hand part of the
screen on and nowhere right before the
cantaloupe or watermelon
blasts her in the face,
they put that up and
half censored her head.
Cause I can guarantee you there
was some woman there going,
this is going to Jeff, it's going
to um, cause violence against women.
How is it going to cause
violence against women?
Because the way the watermelon
just slaps her in the face is Jay.
It was self self-inflicted. That's
one of those things, once again,
those double standard. If a guy did
that, do you think they'd censored?
What if it came back and hit him in his
nuts and he actually lost the ability to
have a child? They still would've shown
that completely uncensored. Wait a minute.
Is this a special guests who
just walked in? Joe, I got lucky.
I got another eight minutes. Just
sit down and help me throw it. Oh,
don't be a fag. Get Elvia pick up
the microphone. Ladies and gentlemen,
look who just walked in. Hey folks, Joe
to Rosa. Oh, are you? Jesus Christ. Joe,
what are you doing here? I uh, you know,
I'm just walking through the studio
bill or I saw you through the glass.
This is like that moment when fucking
Johnny Carson and walked over to, uh,
what's his face,
his sitcom when he was doing CPO.
Sharkey remember that when he broke
his, uh, what's his name? Dom. Dom.
Dom Delouis. Don Rickles. Yeah. He just
kept walking and this is very old school.
Yeah. I just actually alluded to
them. Uh, and not even alluded.
I mentioned that we did a podcast.
I finally did talk to her.
We did a podcast last night,
completely fucking shift faced
and a of the hour and 14 minutes.
How much do you think is going to be
funny that we can actually chop up?
I think at least four minutes
of it was really good.
I think the bulk of it was funny. It,
which was at a good point about like,
it's just a little too much all at once.
Like you got to split it up a little bit
and it just kept meandering and then by
the end I was just really,
I was really getting into your financial
businesses of some deal that you had
and we were like, yeah, we don't, we
don't want that on there. Yeah. Yeah.
Let me tell you about that concept as
business chow. It was really sloppy,
but dude, I got to tell you
a fucking hilarious on it
you to, I loved it. I loved,
I was little. I was, I was kind of an
angry let's that whiskey shit dude bear.
I'm a happy drunk. You know.
Don't blame them. Don't blame
the whiskey bill. No, no.
I'm already angry. But like when I, when
I'm fucking, when I'm sober, I keep,
I keep it in check for the most part, for
the most part, but when I drink whiskey,
then I'm not, if I drink beer, you know,
I got my arm around people and
we'll all go down together.
They're all singing songs. Right.
I'm good time Charlie with the beer.
I start drinking whiskey. Oh, it's
awful. Do. Can you finish chewing?
Whatever's in your mouth to fingernail
is biting my nails through the just
checking. No, I'm sorry. No,
spit it out. You yelled at
me to get over here and shit.
Yeah. What do you want me to
do? I want you to fucking up.
See what happens.
Why be a professional,
you know, Joe, you look at this, you know
I was just going, I just went off on this.
Can you see this woman here? She walked.
She showed up at a, at a NFL practice.
This former Miss Universe here.
Look how she dressed at the practice.
Oh yeah, we're can. Good. She's
hot. Well what? Yeah, and I guess,
and evidently somebody
made some people made,
she was subjected to cat calling Joe.
Can you imagine that?
You could look like that,
dress like that and you can't go to
an NFL practice without getting cash.
She upset about it. Upset. She
tweeted in Spanish that she was,
I'm dying of embarrassment.
She had to cover her ears. Yes.
Well look, I got to say
though, she looks great,
but she is wearing jeans and a shirt.
It's like,
what the hell is she supposed to wear
something? She's in a mini skirt. Okay,
Joe, she's wearing high
heels. Look at a Joe.
How tight of those God damn jeans
righteously today, Really Gel.
What would you do with that
Joe? Uh, Bill, me fucking
leave it in disappointment.
Look,
I'm not looking.
I'm not condoning that you shouldn't.
You shouldn't do that day
she was asking for it.
She was though.
She is Jesus.
What the hell she's supposed
to wear? What's he supposed
to wear? Sweat pants. Joe.
Is it possible for those
genes to get any tighter? No,
but that's how chicks wear their jeans.
Chicks don't wear baggy jeans.
They wear tight jeans and
you know something. Joe,
why don't you just walk back out the
door and bring in the fucking Joe Derosa
that I know. All right. All right,
Joe. He's a no show the rock.
I'm kidding.
What Joe,
if I walk through central park at
three in the fucking morning dress like
Liberace,
singing almond,
the money and I get the shit kicked
out of me and I get mugged, it's wrong.
I should be able to do that,
but do I have any sort of fucking
personal responsibility for my own fucking
safety? All right. You know, we'll go to
a football practice. She's got high heels,
shoes.
She,
you know what first thing that drops a
girls sex sex is down by at least 30% is
when they wear those flats.
Is that the worst when you,
when you're in a relationship and they
get so comfortable that they stopped
jacking their ass up?
Yeah.
And they just wear the flats and
all of a sudden they look like,
like they're a little clown
climbing out of a car. Yeah.
She should have worn those. You're doing
your, you're preaching to the choir. I,
I'm doing a bit of doing it my bit,
a bit in my act right now about take
your lashes like you chose this role and
the why you defending this girl. I'm
saying I'm, I'm you, you convert.
You convinced me.
The centerpiece,
the center centerpiece of
the or the bid is that, uh,
it's about this fat girl cock blocking
me with the skinny girl and doing the
whole angry fat girl thing. And it's
like, yeah, it's just like, you know,
I didn't eat all the egg sandwiches
you did. That was your decision.
You're going to get mad at me that I'm
not leap frogging over your hot friend to
get a shot of your Michelin
man body. Right. That way
there's nothing wrong with
it. You're fat. That's okay.
But take the fucking hit sometimes.
You know what I mean?
It's not fair to everybody else.
You're waltzing around like you're a
piece of tail. You're not, you know,
he's sitting there like a walrus.
Sunning yourself at the bar. Yeah.
But my whole thing too is
like, you know, I'm part Arab.
If I wear a turban on an airplane,
I gotta be ready for a couple
of people to be like, Ooh,
but what the fuck is going on over
here? Come from your territory, dude.
She is. Look at, I'm not
saying that she's a bad person.
She looks like she's fucking gorgeous.
But she doesn't.
She doesn't look like I look at it.
Who was at the shirt she was wearing?
That's the, this is, well that's her at
the super bowl. But is that the shot?
The shot you showed me in the,
in the actual article was the ass shot,
is that what she looked like
from the front? That is her.
I mean that's not her at the practice,
but yeah,
that's what she thinks she's
wearing that night club top.
She's got like the diamonds on the tits.
Tits. Yeah. Glittery tits shirt. Yeah.
It's ridiculous. Glittery
Ted. I mean, look, yeah,
you can't, you got to understand,
this is what pisses me off Joe,
is it's NFL football. It's a guy sport.
There's a bunch of guys playing it.
Nobody asks you to fucking come there.
You inserted yourself into
that situation and this, this,
I'm repeating myself on the podcast,
but just to hear your opinion,
that's when don't you hate that one?
If much guys hanging out and
shooting shit and we're talking,
then I'll send you this. Could skin
with me ski. That's a lady present.
And then all the fun just stops and
everybody has to adjust their fucking
behavior because you're there.
You know what my favorite thing ever
some hate is when,
uh,
like a waitress will say that to a bunch
of drunk guys and there's always the
one 50, you know, the
waitress will go like, uh,
is that how you talk in
front of a lady? And, and uh,
and then there's always one 50
year old drug that goes, well,
why don't you show me a fucking
lady? And I'll tell you, you know,
it's such an old joke, but it always
gets a laugh. It always gets a laugh.
That's just nothing. Uh, you
know, somebody was telling me, um,
I, when I was, I was out in Denver,
they were saying that they will,
they went out to go shoot
pool. Right. So shoot,
now I remember they were shooting
pool and there was a, you know,
they were kicking the shit out of these
guys and there was this group of guys
they had next,
right?
And then some girl Cottey comes up
and she didn't want to fucking wait.
She puts her money down,
but she's so fucking hot that these other
ball is jackasses. They let her cut,
right? And then she's making this big,
and then she's just such a already,
just an arrogant fucking twat
that these guys are like, look,
we don't want to play. We don't want to
play. You were going to play those guys,
right? And she gets blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, giving him shit.
And he goes, look, we're not playing.
You were playing those guys and she
took a full drink and throw it in.
This guy's oof. So I go, well,
you can't hit on. What do you do?
He goes, Oh, this guy's brilliant.
He, he's a spitter. He doesn't,
he just went, she goes, and
he was so fucking, she goes,
what are you going to do?
And you get a hit me. He goes, no,
I'm not going to hit need. Eagles
hit her right in the chest and it
rolled down between her titties.
And this is the worst part. The
bouncers come over, flipping the end.
They fucking of course go. And, and those
guys who she cut all fucking ran it at,
at the dude who just did
that shit. Oh, that's great.
Just immediately fuck it all.
Yeah, because spitting on
somebody is so much worse.
I'd much rather get blasted in the fid.
I even take the brain damage.
Did you ever hear that? Do you ever
that Tony Roberts joke where he's like,
he's like fucked up to hit a woman. I
would never hit all right. I'm bullshit.
Okay.
But he's like, if you put your hands
on me, I'll fucking lay out. He's all,
that's awesome stuff. I could hit
me fine. Don't do this whole bit.
Go see Tony Robbins. Oh wait,
I gotta finish this bit.
It's so funny, Dude. He goes,
you see those commercials?
All right you guys.
Every 12 seconds a woman is hit in
this country. And he goes, he goes,
they don't tell you how every eight
seconds there's a bitch in your face.
Go ahead.
How about buy, buy, buy, buy
baby. And he goes, I warn you,
bitch you at four seconds.
Tony Robbins is one of the most
underrated comedians of all time.
That guy is so fucking ridiculously
talented. He's so funny. Yeah,
I saw him on comedy central buckle.
Ridiculously talented dude.
He's unbelievably humble.
I saw him on comedy central and he,
I think he just starts the bit like this.
He just goes and it was so good because
I fucking hate Wendy Williams. He goes,
Wendy Williams and Danny Glover
or the same motherfucking person.
All right, well we got to
wrap up the podcast here. Joe,
with the squeaky little voice.
It really just annoyed me. Oh me,
Oh,
oh,
here's another youtube video to watch.
Uh, go to [inaudible] dot com, uh,
bill dances. Classic bloopers. Joe
Actually have to show you this one.
This is like a guy trying to do a fishing
show and one of them, I swear to God,
I can't believe that it's actually true.
He's going down the river
and in the distance,
the other cameraman from the two, they're
doing like a two shot the chute, right?
The other camera, first of all is in
the shot and he's edging towards the,
the bank to get a better shop and
it's an eight foot drop into the room.
And that guy with the cake falls
into the fucking river and the,
what's his face? He's one of those redneck
guys who he gets mad, but he's like a,
a classic dude so he doesn't curse.
So he uses like those redneck,
I don't know what the fuck they are,
but he's just add dagnabbit two goes
in the water and push her on it.
It's actually, it's
fucking hilarious. Hey,
I gotta hop in the shower cause Bobby
Kelly's meeting me here in a couple of
[inaudible]. This is Joe. Bobby Kelly can,
he'll come walking through the door. No,
he's going to ring the buzzer and I
gotta run. I gotta get ready here.
So lazy boy. Oh No, it's my show.
I tell you when we're,
when we were up against the heartbreak
and it's time for you to go,
where are you going
Joe? You just going to put it down? He
just going to tap out and walk out. Shower
Jesus. All right, no
problem. Joe. To rose,
everybody Jode Rosa has a new CD out that
I would have hiked, but he walked away.
We'll give me the hype.
What's the hype, Joe?
When does it come out now
Sarah? See John, if it was out,
people would be talking about it. When
does it come out? Oh, Jesus, it's out.
It's called out the depression auction.
Uh, and I endorsed it. Jolene ruck I'm on.
He did when he or eat burned a bit on
the podcast for you. Why am I yelling?
Um, anyways, uh, I think that's going
to be the podcast for this week.
I'm doing a ton of media this week.
Fans of the Opie and Anthony Program.
I believe I'm going to be on there. Uh,
definitely tomorrow. Hopefully Wednesday.
I'm basically going to be on that show
as many days as they'll have me because,
uh, I liked those sons of bitches.
Um, that's it. No, seriously,
if you don't listen to the
opiate Anthony Program,
I don't know what your problem is.
Get an XM satellite,
whatever the Fuck Sirius XM player.
And check those guys out. Watch a little
bit of this stuff on Youtube. They're, uh,
they're, they're fucking awesome. So
I'm going to be doing them this week.
I'll probably be doing something
on versus, and um, you know what,
as I do them, if they're not live
and they're going to be shown later,
I'll just on the [inaudible] podcast,
we'll have that information up there.
But if you didn't get the,
Oh, gee, she's ring tone,
you can go to the [inaudible] podcast.com
and on the left hand corner you'll see
it right there. And you just
click on o g g and you can get it,
put it in your phone. And then whenever
the biggest company life calls you up,
that's what your phone is going to
be saying. Oh, gee, gold beach. Um,
if you don't, don't do it. I don't give
a fuck. I'm just happy you listening.
All right, you guys have a great week and
a, that's my prediction. Ravens will win.
Um, and I dunno, jets, jets are
patriots. I gotta be honest with you.
Could go either direction,
but I'm really liking what I watched
on the ticker tape on the airplane.
I have no fucking idea. I miss. I don't,
I can't judge the Patriots, but uh,
and I think the jets
are going to get best.
Mike go tenant six after
all that fucking Yip. Yap.
And they'll probably make it into
the playoffs. God knows they got,
they got enough talent
on the fucking team,
but I think all this shit talking is
really going to hurt him and I don't,
I don't think they're going to
go as far as they went last year.
What do you think about that?
Huh? What do you think about that?
Jets play like a jet.
What the fuck does that mean?
You haven't won one since 1969.
What does that mean?
Get your fans all excited and then
you shit the bed in January. What Gel?
That's what they do. Oh,
they haven't won since.
We were excited that we landed on the
moon like that was going to lead to new
real estate.
That was the last time they want Joe.
I was six months old. Joe, six months old.
Curt Gowdy announced the last
time that they want a super bowl.
All right. Jim Morrison
was still alive. Joe,
Jimi Hendrix was still putting out albums,
Joe to Rosa the last time they won.
And this same play like a jet
all the way.
I liked that west side story.
That really is where we differ.
You're talking about the jets and I'm
singing the song that sounds like one of
the oldest.
They're really into that old school shit.
You know what the sad thing
about the jets are there?
The only professional franchise and all
four sports that actually sublet their
stadium. Yeah, it,
they play a giant stadium there.
You know what they are?
Joe didn't like that fucking
loser who never moves out.
And that window of getting married and
actually meeting somebody just closes and
then they just say fuck it.
And they're just waiting for the last of
their alive parent to die so that they
can think they can take
over the house. Uh, podcast.
Jesus. Joe, look at you. Come up with a
little bit of anger. Joe. You know what?
I hate out uninsured. Unashamed.
You are about your torso.
I give Joe Shit because his body, he
looks like an adolescent. Will Ferrell.
Like what picture will
Ferrel's body at 23?
Joe, have you ever done a pull
up in your life? Do you like,
do you even have those muscles now?
He left me.
I was really going to compare him to
like the Camaro rally sport. You know,
somebody goes out and you get the Iraq,
right? You've got the air conditioner,
you got the tee tops,
you get the electric windows,
and then you had the rally sport,
which you basically had the same body,
but you didn't have those options.
I was going to go that route.
Is that what you were going to do,
Bill,
where you're going to do it in a funny
way because the way you presented that it
wasn't too funny. All right, that's
the podcast for this week. Uh,
God bless all of you guys.
Let's go ravens.
Fuck the jets and a,
I'm hoping this time next week that jets
are fucking oh into and if they are all
went, I'm telling you right now,
Rex Ryan, I am Guaran fucking team.
It will cry during a press conference
and he's going to be crying and his
fucking, you know, bodies
going to be jiggling.
I hate the jets. I hate the jets more
than I hate the cults now, you know,
kind of helps it. They lost to
the Texans. But yeah, the jets,
I want nothing more than to watch
them eat their fucking words.
The arrogance of that fucking teeth.
Look at that and you don't even know
how to behave when there's a lady in the
room. All right. Who gives a fuck?
Ravens are going to win tonight.
I'm going to have an extra 50 bucks in.
The Patriots are going to
beat him next week. All right?
That's what my heart says. All
right, you guys have a good week.
Please watch my special Sunday night,
September 19th 11:00 PM okay.